we're gonna have a lot of fun and uh again hikaru
versus fedo save these guys have played so much
on chess.com i don't have the stats in front of
me i'm sure the team will their lifetime record
obviously favors nakamura but as you said there's
even been recent times where they throw down in
casual chess and fedo saif has that ability to
get the better of hikara we've seen it happen
right we also know that like artemyev we say
this about the motherland a lot right robert
sometimes there's just super gm's just hanging
around in russia right guys like fedor sam and
artemyev aren't as as big a household names as
as grishak or uh nepamyashi but they're they're
very good and very capable oh for sure i mean the
russian super finals coming up i heard you wish
artemy of well there you have peter svidler who's
won that eight times and because of the likes of
svidler grifsherk as you just mentioned karjakin
etc these other players who are super strong don't
get the attention that they would if they were
from a country less populated by chess superstars
right yeah and uh it's the the culture there
you know the uh the amount of uh chess that
people are exposed to at a young age uh we we
talked about the fact that fedo said actually
grew up in the same town as a niche geary uh last
time vladimir here was on camera anishgiri was my
co-commentator as uh he took on albireza farouza
so there's just a lot a lot of chess stars from a
lot of different places around russia and then we
have the man himself the american the number one
chess streamer in the world sporting his hoodie
by the way sportingthechest.com hoodie i got you
one of those right robert yeah you did uh i just
i don't wear it but i i have it somewhere i know
but i was about i thought you were gonna do the
thing we're like no danny you didn't which proves
you love a car or more and you're i thought we
were gonna have the whole fight but we didn't
have to do that it was so cool are you trying to
start fights just to prove how you know well we
get along like that's what you're doing just so
we can you know how i you know how much i love
fighting because of the makeup chess you and i
have the best makeup chest in the business buddy
um all right are we about to cut cut this
chess you will tension with a knife i'm ready
i don't know who else is ready i mean i think a
car in federer look at federer by the way yeah
he's he's looking ready to go i mean he he's got
like that that boxer hoodie on right and he's got
he's got that white and red combo i mean the guy
is just he's in for a battle and he's got a car
nakamura ahead that is as tough as it gets him
alongside magnus carlson you're playing them for
hours you're going to be in for it but what do you
think danny so fedo say of underdog he knows that
we know that what does he need to do to give
himself the best chance in the first few games
i i kind of feel like he needs to strike early you
know hammer and i talked a lot about the momentum
the underdog needs in terms of getting two wins in
a row that feels like the magical number which by
the way artemia was not able to do until the final
minutes of bullet right so it did prove right that
the thing about the top seed is when they lose
they very rarely lose again and i think if the
upset is gonna happen you have to find a way
whether it's in the five minute or the three
minute portion to put their back against the wall
because yeah they're good but they also don't have
to play with those tilt emotions as often as
others so if you can put hikaru in that spot
will he be able to recover from what could
be consecutive losses so i'll say robert
the answer to the question is no matter where it
happens at some point fedo say needs to win two
games in a row to have a chance here and this is
going to be a funny statement before we get into
the chess specifics but obviously hikar nakamura
has the most wins on the server he plays so much
but he also has a large number of losses just
because of the quantity of games he has played he
wins way more often but he does have experience
losing and that may not sound important but as
you're saying fedozer will need to win a couple
in a row and when carl plays there are times
where some other very strong grandmaster gets a
couple hikara calms himself down and then ends up
winning the match anyway so right now out of the
gates we have the semi-solve a solid structure for
black look at this pawn triangle heading towards
the center it means that it's going to be a hard
central position to crack even though that light
square bishop on c8 dany reminds us of the french
we hate it when we're reminded of
the french the opening not the people
uh but yeah no the uh the bishop there at some
point the pawn chain will break we just talked
a lot about this in the carlson versus artemiv
match because the semi-slot was featured regularly
never this exact variation though i will note for
the record uh but here goes hicaro speeding up a
little bit after a think before playing bishop g5
um and uh we have a semi-slav didn't quite reach
a baud vinnick variation but that's because white
sacrifices the bishop pair to have the big center
what what's going on in this structure as black
tries to prepare for the liberating breakthroughs
what's white doing to be ready for that yeah white
has a choice you can play knight e4 or you could
have played 94 to actually get the bishop off the
board the d6 bishop but he likes his knight on c3
he wants to push his pawns in the center because
the best way to challenge pieces are with pawns
and if you do play e4 the one thing you always
have to be ready for is e5 or c5 black will try to
break in return and more broadly speaking the d4
square is less protected so even if black doesn't
break with the pawn at some point d4 could be a
potential issue yeah well hikaru's thinking now
and actually chooses queen d3 instead of e4 and a
quick castles from the big fish rook d1 preparing
to meet e5 and c5 the tactical way perhaps um
and so black being down in development and white
preparing the center the structure is still very
solid for black but you have to be careful because
if too much prep is done and you still haven't
changed the formation now the space can get
real right and it can be hard to react so what is
what is fedocide going to be thinking about here
a common idea is to actually play for b5 at
some point and then uh you advance your queen
side pause this is a double-edged sword because
playing b5 gives black critical space on the queen
side and it also gives the bishop access on a new
diagonal he does go for b6 a calmer approach i
think that you know going forward depending on the
match situation the difference between b6 and b5
will be noticeable it will vladimir play something
a little more aggressive now he says it's game one
i don't need to take these big structural risks
i'm gonna play b6 i'm going to play bishop b7
i'm going to prepare my pawn break with c5 or
e5 when the time is 100 correct yeah and that's
what we're going to go for but while we have the
analysis board i'll just say again the b5 while
it is more structurally committal it's also the
very common idea which is why robert said we'll
probably see it black can follow with a6 and c5
is still eventually coming with the diagonal so
really just an interesting stylistic choice but
i'll say showing hey it's early in the match
let me take a little more flexible of an approach
here where i'm preparing still both of these moves
uh before i've committed anything so uh
we see uh both guys pretty focused hikara
in a position he's now known very well for
streaming uh regularly every day and then
vladimir putin will say we've gotten to know that
bookshelf behind him despite the hoodie being new
yeah he yeah he's a familiar face these days and
he is trying to combat the uh aggressive approach
now by hikar putting the bishop to a6 trying to
take advantage of the compromised light squares on
the queen side you have a bishop there for now but
i'm getting rid of what doesn't look like a great
piece just to take advantage of the remaining
squares and by the way danny i'm looking at it
fedo sayo's internet connection not very good
continuing to go to one bar and actually that's
probably why he's spending so much time less so
about the actual chest position it seems like uh
he's struggling with that connection well we
actually see him uh he's actually he's he's
frozen completely elsa he needs to let
it go right reset and reboot the router
um you know what they say about that spotty wi-fi
right sometimes the wi-fi router is capable of
more than your connection and you know never mind
whole thing but no but jokes aside that's actually
really too bad remember it is part of the rules
part of the game the players are responsible for
a great connection we will see what happens
we have fedor say of on the line or not
yeah and uh hickar waiting here i i wonder if
he realizes he could see the bar of connection
on top of the screen but you know sometimes the
players like to look at the zoom calls just as
if they're playing over the board yeah i wonder if
he is i bet he does i bet he does um in fact there
we go we see the zoom call drop and while we wait
for the reconnection why don't we bring back the
bracket because i want to talk about one thing
real quick before the game starts which is that
this is the last seat that has not been filled yet
so for those who somehow maybe missed the earlier
part of today's double header magnus carlson did
move on so there is only one spot remaining before
we have a full semi-final bracket remember the
semi-finals and finals will take place december
11th 12th and 13th 100 mark your calendar next
week and going to be a busy one and we're back
the the chess is back we don't know the players
on camera yet but we'll keep the chess going rook
b8 was played by the way followed by an exchange
robert as you said this eliminates the defense
of the c6 pawn how cecaro gonna take advantage
of that he has his options here i'm wondering
if he will ever play the move e3 to e4 it doesn't
need to instead use it for the knight and that's
something that he has been keeping away from this
pawn push so that he can keep the square open for
night that hits the bishop on d6 but also opens
the c file the rook on c1 staring down the pawn
on c6 the a6 square in addition to c6 is white's
for the taking so fedoceav not only has internet
connection issues he has control issues with all
these squares on the queen side and the bishop
on d6 is particularly useless for the time
being that's a dark square piece there are no
dark squares that you're really wanting to take
advantage of and in fact it's a bit superfluous
with that queen sitting there on e7 you're not
you're stepping on each other's toes you're not
actually controlling too much so the knight on e4
is much better than this bishop on d6 right now
yeah i will say we often talk about a centralized
knight being able to keep pace with a bishop
that's better on the long diagonals and open
board i will say i like the way federal safe is
coordinated to to deal with the weakness and don't
forget that in these structures even though you've
had less space for a really long time and maybe
not ideal pieces as we were just highlighting if
the pieces get traded and you eventually kind of
simplify the long-term advantages of that carroll
slob structure is it's very solid there's there's
no other real weaknesses long-term besides the c6
pawn um we'll see what a car can do now we're glad
to see fedo say of having fixed his internet woes
whatever they were back to a four bar connection
on chess.com and a and a beautiful zoom camera and
a beautiful subscription right there from shine90
thank you so much for the support everybody
it's been a great day and i mean for you it's been
a long day already for me i i was watching you
and hammer hammer did a great job by the way you
always do a great job i don't need to compliment
you but hammer was excellent uh very sharp and uh
youtube made a great team uh but danny i gotta say
this connection for fedor say it is concerning
me he needs to be at his absolute best to
put up a fight with takara nakamura yeah his
internet connection not doing him any favors
right now it's kind of it's time to go tell junior
to stop downloading netflix right hey you've
seen nemo seven times no more watching nemo or
streaming on netflix when dad's playing in the scc
oh gosh one bar and uh you know unfortunately
for him his position is okay and from his
chess specific point of view he gets in c5 and
if you accomplish that you were just saying danny
black's position is very stable you're getting
rid of your weakness there were two rooks on
a semi-open file aiming towards that pawn now
it's on a square protected by all these other
pieces we're trying to trade it off and then
liquidate into an equal ending so maybe i was
overly harsh about the position for black i
tend to not like these more passive structures
better say perfectly fine over the board as for
the internet connection dave that he's got to fix
that for sure he does he's back to one bar though
it's bouncing all around this is why i said it
it actually you know jokes aside and as personal
as that sounded uh i do fight my daughters for the
netflix man with on a regular basis uh there may
be something going on seriously at home because
this we know federal sam's internet is stable
i did a whole match with him versus ferugia
never had that problem he plays on
chess.com in the dozens of games daily so
whatever's going on jokes aside he does need
to fix his his wifi and this actually might
be a very serious thing because taking on f6
with the queen or the the pawn that's not as
easy of a decision as many people would think
oh why would i double my pawns with g takes f6
but it by taking with the queen on f6 and he does
take with the pawn there could be tactics related
to knight e4 gaining a tempo at a critical moment
so instead he takes with the pawn that was just
pure chest thought and he is okay because at the
end of the day the king will just slide up to g7
protect those pawns and the open g file isn't
enough for white to work with you don't have
a queen and a rook and pieces starting to
checkmate the king so like i think there's a good
decision by fedor say up there it's such a
good point and i like to say it's sometimes
how chess knowledge has evolved right robert over
the years we see that there's the dynamic factors
of opening up the king and in some cases a quick
switch where the king gets active in the end game
make g takes f6 not just a necessity but a better
move and oh my god hikaru goes to queen sac town
but is this a good decision i don't think so look
at carl's time by the way i didn't even notice
that he was the one in more time trouble and with
the d4 pawns hanging knight if it covers the e1
score there's no checkmate but it felt like for a
moment there black should be doing well i saw the
eval bar in black's favor and now it's about level
uh this is going to be a difficult one to assess
i like the two rooks though danny now that
the smoke is cleared i agree let's bring back
the analysis board because we'll probably analyze
just a little bit of that queen sack um but again
quickly ricardo played queen a6 having calculated
this idea of sacrificing the queen for two rooks
where was the better approach for black
i don't know but it wasn't queen before
and in the end hecarim seems to be coordinating
and figuring it out despite time pressure look at
those two rooks about to do dirty work on the back
rank all right but here f5 is good it gives the
king square but that's what you need to do two
rooks are better than a queen because they can
team up on a square an f7 is that square it's a
light square that bishop can't help in its defense
so it looks like this is hikaru's game right now
and uh unless something goes really drastically
wrong oh that's i thought it was something going
wrong too what happened there he got he hit both
rooks in a row but hikaru saw more than either
and rookie five hit the queen in return and
now he can bring the rook oh he actually had
rook takes e6 there too but he didn't see it
yeah he's oh okay but there's no way that king
walks uh survives that walk in the park and rook
g7 forcing rook h4 that's an owie yeah and uh
and hikaru does do what he came to do which is
strike first here in the same game let's bring
back the analysis board we'll take a quick look
at how that one finished again the threat that
was unstoppable was rook h4 mate but the federal
saves credit if he sits tight there's threats
of rook f4 rook takes e6 is on the agenda there
really weren't a lot of options right robert yeah
now can we just go back quickly to that bishop
uh before this hitting both rooks what vision
by hikara because i'm freaking out like oh he
blundered but he saw that he had this rook e5 move
and black's queen is forced away from all of the
uh action and that just goes on to win a clean
game there yeah and uh i'm not sure what else
black could have done here to maintain a closer a
closer level uh the computer seems to think maybe
keep the queen on the diagonal is a little more
awkward but i'm with you that it'll probably work
the hook on d6 gets trapped what the rook on d6
gets trapped after queen b7 oh wait oh my god
that's the idea that's crazy yeah nobody's
saying that would just if the rook goes
here probably bishop e7 like gosh what a hard
move to see and then after rookie eight just
to finish this off i think there's queen
d7 and after rook b8 is finally bishop g6
yeah what a ridiculous oh my god that's why it's a
computer we don't i don't have the computer moves
in front but that that's nuts robert and you saw
it well but it's funny is white's probably still
holding that position if no longer better
but federal state did not see it as we said
he moved the queen away and hikaru does the job
we'll stay right here on the analysis board and
remind everybody real quick of the opening we
missed because we were focused on reviewing that
what do we have here robert we had a
queen's indian slash catalan opening
ikaro plays into mainline stuff with dc4 stop
me if there's something you want to chat about
not really the bishop on g2 being a very powerful
piece and that's why hikar brings the bishop out
the way he does is to challenge that bishop on
g2 you do not want to allow that to sit there and
dominate we've seen kramnik do that for so many
years it's not very pleasant for black yeah 100
this is a kind of a typical catalan you you
fee encountered the bishop so to speak by hand
rather than the traditional b6 and bishop
b7 but this is all very equal stuff and
i believe something i've seen these two guys
played before i uh i don't i don't make a habit
of just sitting and watching players on the
chess.com server but i feel like this opening
is going to be repeated today we know
federosayev likes a catalan and look at
this idea here he gives up the b7 pawn with this
nice c5 tactic exposing the pin on the d2 bishop
who's better here i'm starting like black's
position i think this is a hikaru nakamura
at his best because uh that move rook a to d8
that he played ignoring the fact that b7 was
hanging which looked really bad honestly because
the knight in a6 stalls in trouble he just saw
a little bit uh further ahead and right now we're
at a position after the bishop captured instead
of you know black would play c6 for example to
stop the fish from capturing but here you trade
knights c5 will fall the rook on d2 is so powerful
you're going to control the only fully opened file
by bringing your f to d8 it just seems like all of
the pluses in the position are for black and white
is temporarily you know just looking okay with the
opposite bishops but you just don't have a plan
well that line i was just showing with knight e4
bishop e4 the question i would ask you is should
black take here or just maybe or honestly even
f5 is a move right you gain a tempo and then win
c5 actually yeah five actually is probably good
not hanging h7 i totally forgot about that pawn
i wasn't aware of the entire board they are so
focused on how good it looked for black but f5
looks like a good starting point for black not
being aware of the whole board makes me think
maybe you should do a lesson series on full
board awareness i don't think you're uh you
know hinting at anything are you maybe maybe not
uh use chess.com lessons for all your uh all your
chess improvement needs by the way um anyway
jokes aside queen f6 coming with the c5 pawn
hanging means that f2 will be under pressure he
is giving up h7 by the way i really like that move
this is this is risky to go for this one now
black is threatening g6 to win the bishop b2
is falling oh my gosh and bishop takes c5 yeah
that's a pawn that you really want to take but
you understand the consequences are too great so
bishop takes h7 will lose white material and now i
think the move that should be played i don't have
the lines from it i see the bar is about level but
i'm having a hard time finding moves which means
something like maybe rook to a2 just to it's a
disgusting looking move but it protects the pawn
on b2 and i don't think you can afford to give
up b2 while your rook on e1 is hanging you can't
move your rook from e1 because then e2 is hanging
i see all these problems so i'm just looking at
rook a2 and hoping yeah that this doesn't look
good rook takes beats for this but rook b2 and
bishop b1 is coming by the way funny line if you
played rook a2 i wonder if rook takes b2 was still
possible because the bishop takes e1 i only had
that idea by the way you described the position
so it's definitely clear that federal state
have had a lot to figure out so hard to hold it
against him now we'll see if hikaru can convert on
what are the tactics i why not just take and take
what's he waiting for there we go uh i'm not sure
bishop takes e1 i don't see a response i mean
the rook on b2 is safe and sound he's just
okay so maybe this is what he was thinking about
he wasn't thinking about okay do i play rook b2
do i take the rook of course he saw that but he
was trying to figure out the response afterwards
so he didn't have to spend time at that moment and
that's something that we know hikaru does better
than anybody is figuring out these moments of when
you should spend your time and when you should
force your opponent uh clock to start ticking but
you know making the move and i think that's what
he was going for there it's somebody who said that
because it's it's you and i say this a lot it's
not taking your time it's time management right in
a position where he knows he's holding the cards
he makes sure he's super precise and then he
can rattle off several moves so in the critical
moment that his opponent wasn't thinking of in
his head now that person has to think about it
on their time and it sounds silly but it's a
super important thing to develop in terms of
your own maturity and discipline as a chess player
to manage your clock and don't be in a rush just
because the moves are obvious um just for example
if it caro had rattled off that whole idea and
then paused to think him and his opponent would
both be thinking about the same position instead
the mystery makes fedor say i'm not sure where the
game is going exactly and well this position here
it is a rook for a bishop and one pawn there's
actually quite a bit of compensation for white
white's king on g2 not going to be in too much
danger unless somehow you can get a useful check
and take over the second or the last rank the
good thing for white is that the bishop one b5
is so powerful it's defended by a pawn that's good
news it defends both a4 and c6 on the queen side
it also comes back to defend upon an e2 it's doing
everything so now the question is how does black
break through the position is great you are
better you're up a rook for just a bishop and
an h pawn that's not relevant just yet but how
do you win the game and not just stand better
yeah it's a great question and originally my plan
was going to be to suggest just move the queen and
double the rooks on the second ring but as you
highlighted the bishop is already kind of prepared
for that right it's really not clear this is one
of those positions where the eval bar can throw
you off yes black is materially better but lack
of a plan is uh super hard to deal with for black
and we'll see hikar brings the pawn up to g5
one thing that he could try to go for it and
that's why h3 was played out if he can get
g4 it's not double the rooks in the h file
that h2 pawn was on a dark square so he puts
the pawn on h3 not allowing his pawns to become
totally backward on that side of the board and
danny let me give you a bunch of free moves
obviously you're not gonna just take my bishop
and move away but some you know realistic moves
what is black's plan what are you gonna do if
i gave you three free moves right now right
let's go to the analysis board maybe analyze
it a little bit and figure it out because
okay so let's say white just sits to prove
the point that robert's making and i don't
know forget what the eval bar is saying our point
is even things like this it's not totally clear i
mean this this would blunder for example it would
under the rook but the point is even if you do
obvious things it's not clear where you're
better right how do you make progress here
in this position we see that f3 played by federal
save also not bad because here's what he's saying
this pawn is already guarded i got you i got
your back right the bishop is taking care of
all the little guys here it certainly is i'm
really trying to come up with a plan perhaps it
involves trading a pair of rooks but if you trade
a pair of rooks then you can't gang up on a pawn
so that's the downside the good thing if you
can imagine the rook on c1 the rook on d8
being off the board now you have to watch out
for rook takes b5 sacrifices and the eight pawn
going through so that's in the back of my mind
i'm not quite sure that uh hikara can make that
work but those are the some of the ideas that
you should be considering no it's a great point
uh just to always be aware that when you're up
the exchange you have the ability to give it back
if the chance uh it comes so rook to c3 black is
maybe now going to try to switch to the first rank
um how does fedocide deal with that rook to c5
oh nice he's going to move the bishop from from
b5 to hit a5 and ricardo says no thank you yeah i
guess exchanging the rooks allows that black king
just walk into the game which is why federer
says keeping a rook on the board but your idea
of going for a checkmate honestly by bringing
the rooks down to the first rank that could be
quite scary for white to deal with yeah just
to illustrate what could happen forget the the
popularness of the whether that's likely but
f4 eventually comes and the point is that move
holds e3 from escaping it holds g3 so if you're
wondering what is kind of the abstract mating net
in fact uh that abstract idea was stopped by fedo
sam precisely because it might become a reality um
but this is what akara wants right when you have
the rooks you want these kind of moves being
made the more pawns advance the more potential
targets are created the more the rook can flex
for sure and it's very difficult for white because
that rook on c3 could never find an open file
and here's no exception rook g3 i play rook g1
check i trade off the rook so federal save needs
to somehow get his rook to attack either c7 or a5
but that car has stopped it completely by putting
the rook on a1 keeping the bishop frozen on b5 and
now the rook on c3 can't swing over to g3 at least
not yet yeah hicaro can play a little tickle if he
wants only 18 seconds for fedo sev almost 30 for
recaro we haven't talked too much about the time
these guys have been close to level in both games
so far um oh wait but now yeah now uh nice both
ropes a net is ensuing i feel like we're about
to have a fanciful rook finish here fancy feet
look at that bishop f1 was nice couldn't take
it because the rook hung everybody that's funny
you know it's a good try the position is losing
so he went for uh just a little trick not working
a car too strong and this is going to be hikaru's
second win in a row yep and it was it was a nice
hold there for quite some time by fedo save now
the bishop will fall on king g1 the move is rook
a1 winning the bishop and sophosaev resigns but
robert i feel like there's deja vu here right you
and i have done a lot of hikaru nakamura matches
and sometimes we have games like that where
like that was really close the opponent played
well and and we're we're heading into
time pressure and then all of a sudden
like i can't even point back to exactly the
turning moment but hikaru walks away with the dub
and i you know i said i'll move 15 or so that was
the best of hikaru nakamura i just saw the way
he was playing and i've had the pleasure and the
pain honestly of playing hikaru for many years now
uh first over the board and of course online and
you know you recognize the way that he plays over
time and there depends on the match situation
depends on the event but that is just vintage
hikaru just getting tactical not giving his one
any chances freezing his opponents pieces in ways
that they can't improve their position and then
just maneuvering in a way that uh increases your
advantage right karu is in very good shape i would
say the first game he wasn't um maybe as precise
as he needed to be federsev was getting out of it
any car was a bit slow on the clock but then i do
believe that fedo saves connection issues caused
hikaru some psychological problems a car does not
want to win because of some internet connection
issue so i think game one that was for both sides
something that you know you forget about it it
was a victory for a car of course good for the
scoreboard but we won't see that type of play
happen again here's a knight on e5 to prove that
point well and and good to know knock on wood so
far we hopefully won't see internet connectivity
issues again for fedor save because since that
first game we haven't really seen any problems
by the way shout out to all the subs we have
coming in your support of the channel means the
world honestly it's why these events are possible
you and our premium members we appreciate it and
throw us your prime we have another primetime
smackdown match coming up at the break um and uh
and uh subscribers will get to watch it in full
with no commercials so all right 95 played this
is one of those early moves that has it wasn't
as popular in the traditional or you know
renaissance years of the queen's gambit if you
will like it was moving a piece twice breaking
opening principles but white goes for this stuff
a lot now as sort of a catapult to f4 coming in
and launching the potential of a kingside attack
um what do you think about this response to it
with dtx c4 i think that fidosev was getting
concerned he was burning quite a bit of time
and i liked 95. i think that when your opponent
placement was like h6 and it plays a bit slower
you can just hop into the center and i like the
decision there by hikaru to take with the knight
instead of developing the bishop and recapturing
the pawn he moves his knight a third time
and the large reason why is when your opponent has
less space you do not want to trade their pieces
off and the knight on d7 cramps the bishop on c8
now the d file opens but i do think that fedor
save isn't in bad shape even if so far hikaru has
i think a slight little pull out of the opening
well we've seen knight d6 check to gobble the
bishop parrots probably not really that big of
a deal uh the knight can be traded and despite
the dark squares black can quickly offer a queen
trade and and equalize uh in the end game but it
is the bishop here and we know how hammer would
feel about the bishop here right um let's bring
up the analysis board real quick just to show
what robert was talking about h6 was played and
because of that loss of tempo so to speak hikaru
doesn't have to be asked to gain a tempo
himself with knight e5 and dc4 like you
said you keep the pieces on the board when your
opponent has less space don't let them trade it
now c5 takes takes and we're seeing that hikara
will not waste time trying to get the bishop
here just plays bishop e2 and i expect him to
castle right after fedor say if he's just done so
and back down to one bar hopefully that fixes
itself it does seem like it you know it goes
back to normal um but his position is okay right
now with the black pieces you traded off two pawns
you have some open lines that you
can work with uh the issue that
can potentially happen is you look at this
knight on c4 and you start worrying yourself
about it getting to d6 because when knight d6
happens you win a bishop but i'm going to put
win in air quotes because do you really want that
bishop on c8 danny you know better than anyone
how i feel about that bishop on c8 yeah i showed
the dark square bishop would not be what you want
to use robert's air quotes this would be a problem
on the dark squares but uh giving up the light
square bishop would probably be fine okay so
knight d6 is played i expect to move like queen
e7 right this move a double attacks the knight and
kind of forces the trade so that then you've given
up a bad piece for a good piece there well federal
staff plays 95 even better in terms of a double
attack the same trade happens and and i like
federal state's position here this is uh the best
i think middle game that the big fish has had all
day it looks to be the case for sure even though
white has the two bishops advantage that i think
we talk about that so much that people think is
when i get the two bishops i am better definitely
not here though and the reason why is look at how
active black's pieces are you have a rook on
the open c file a knight on e5 uh you can play
b4 at some moment i would not play that at
least not unless i'm provoked because that
opens up the light square bishop on the entire
diagonal uh what i will say though is it's not
easy for black to come up with a plan here and
it feels like white is relying on the fact that
hey if i can trade some pieces in the long term
the bishop hair will be superior to the knights
it's a good point because even we've had this so
many times where you know the optics look great
but where's the ability to improve it the
long-term factors might favor the person who has a
piece that you lack and in this case you mentioned
b4 being risky but also white has a4 as a common
plan here these positions he doesn't go for a4 now
kind of slow jams this he's going to take his time
um but it doesn't change that the long-term
light squares could be a problem for pedo-save
i think so and i asked this question pretty
much uh every day what is black's plan if i
gave you three free moves and i'm not quite
seeing it whereas for white i see plenty of
different options uh bishop e1 i was going to
mention rook to c1 can happen knight a2 is a
common remaneuvering of the piece opening up
your bishop on e1 for some longer diagonal and
giving you the option to play a4 or knight
b4 so it's a flexible approach for white
and black on the other hand making logical
moves just not consequential ideas yeah
makes sense um and he does answer a little bit
of your question if you gave me three moves what
would i do apparently i'm going to double on the
c file if i'm pedal save but that's always a good
question to ask yourself it's not just a sort of
abstract one there from grand master robert hess
if you ask yourself what your next three moves
are not fantasy chess and find a way to coordinate
often that is suggesting something
you should go for all right 95 but
i like just bishop f3 at some point i'm
threatening knight before my bishops are coming
out and you're right it feels like white has more
chances to improve than black and that hikara
phase says can i still go knight to b4 because
i've ruined my pawn structure sure but a takes b4
makes my rook a glorious piece on a1 he goes wow
knight back to c3 instead yeah that's surprising
just gonna repeat now maybe he'll play bishop
f3 first if he really was irritated about that
to prevent knight d5 and go back to his plan but
a funny thing is is that moving the knight also
kind of prevented this knight from moving
because of the threat here so if you don't
maybe federal safe has plans for a knight at five
knights c4 right so he's not quite sure what to do
here and he's now he's under a minute i'm with
you i was about to mention the clock as well
it's we're not used to seeing hikaru down so
much time and that you know you got to give it
credit to fedoceof who despite losing two games
he's still in his element he's just playing good
moves and doing it relatively quickly very
much in a hikaru nakamura style but ikaru
i like what he just did there he goes knight to
a2 he recognizes hey this position was actually
good for me and fedor save also realized the
same and did not play knight d5 once more
the second time around we're gonna get knight b4 i
expect him to take what the bishop he does and now
after the queen moves i think just bishop f3
no a4 he says no no no dan the bishop's right
where it belongs buddy let's undermine and make
some targets and this is a tough choice here for
fedocerv you can capture on a4 which most of the
time is the incorrect decision because you give
access to attack your weak pawn on a6 uh but here
there could be some tactics along rook c1 ideas
because of the real takes on a4 you lose control
of your first rank so i would think about politics
a4 i wouldn't want to play it and that's why he
does not play it braids yeah that's interesting
maybe he should have though look at that move
bishop he won he keeps the pieces on the board
but maybe maybe it wasn't his best because now
you can't actually take this pawn everybody um and
just to show you couldn't take it before because
if you did the the pin would win um but i'll say
of keeping this thing leveled the b pawn will it
prove to be a target or a strength if you can keep
it on the board and get some counter play you'll
be all right but ricardo ricardo's gonna make it
really hard to keep that pawn the b4 pawn is very
bad for black in an end game but it's very good
for black in the current dynamic because look at
that bishop on e1 it's just staring at that pawn
can't capture it but in endgames then white's king
will just run over to the queen side and start
trying to attack that pawn so i like what feather
saves doing at this moment and watch out for some
kind of bishop c3 for white because the rook
on b8 is not protected so bishop c3 could be a
possible move ooh it's a great idea take advantage
of the pin hit the rook on v8 but federal state is
working it watch the queen at night get surgical
up in these light squares you got to watch out
he plays the rook back i expect queenie for
check at some point that'll save up more than
a minute on the clock this is a rare situation
to see hikaru in such self-induced time pressure
yeah and look at fedo say he is locked into
his screen right now trying to figure out
a way forward it's looking good for him the king
on g2 in worse shape than the king on g7 he plays
knight g4 what is it threatening is there some
kind of attack not quite figuring it out here
queen f6 retreats i like b3 you're being patient
but notice federal save has put the pressure on f2
hard to believe it you don't really want
to part ways with the light squares here
right that's an instructor point you're taking
a knight gives it you lose that bishop you lose
control over the light squares so i would say
here for fedocero he's trying to figure out can
i do something with the double works on the c
file but you're offering a rook trade if you
move the bishop out the way and maybe then he's
not seeing a way to continue pressing forward i
like the look of his position i just
don't see how you knock black out here
okay now he ends up retreating tonight which
just feels awkward and we're getting into
mutual time pressure now between players
you're right position go ahead no you go ahead
oh no b4 hangs you go ahead whoa and if bishop
takes before rook takes c7 but then a5 is hanging
at the end of this whole thing so too much yeah
i was going to take on c7 first take an a5 but
then white has stolen a pawn but i see that
somehow going to get the better of this and hikaru
i don't want to say swindles because it was also
concrete but the way that converted was uh was
awkward and look at that move takes advantage if
you take e2 i get the knight oh but now you lose
b3 okay so we should probably have a draw here
turns out queen a7 was not the best approach and
is fedo say of trying to play for a win because
he did not trade queens there and i think it's
the right call he is a knight against a bishop
we talk about this all the time knights can go
from color complex to color complex bishop stuck
on its diagonal so i actually think that playing
for a win is not a bad shot i agree and even if
objectively this should be a draw you see the
computer puts up the donut over there all zeroes
but from a practical perspective with humans
the knight holds all the cards when everything
is on one side of the board flex from one color to
another see if you can poke some weaknesses loose
um not doing it yet but still time i think
he kind of played tickle there robert to
gain a little bit of time on the increment he
did and he in what g4 was queen before check
oh he missed that yeah oh that was not
ideal no sir but you know what it is
ideal in terms of defense again light square
bishop you can control the dark squares and h8
corner doesn't match that bishop just the thing
i'm thinking about right now not gonna fool robert
has twice in the same 24 hours he will he will
mention that early for those who uh watched lavon
aronian versus mvl yesterday you get that
inside joke and i love you more than others
um we're likely gonna have a draw as robert said
even if somehow you converted this knight at
this point could probably sack for the pawn as
long as you can ensure h4 h4 play h4 right now
he should have played h4 make the pawn come to
the corner no he didn't do it any lost in time
oh my god no oh wow oh his head's in his hand
oh my god all the applauding he defended so
well oh wow that's that is a heartbreaking way
to start your your upset campaign against the
number one overall seed in hikaru nakamura to
the batcave we go we gotta look at it here we go
omgs are snaps it's a draw it's a drawn position
but he loses on time but robert's point is still
a good one if you just play h4 here look at this
h4 brilliant by fedo sayev knight check and sack
so even though he he loses on time and it still
feels unfair robert's not wrong that the heads-up
play still would have been better by fedo sayev
force the pawn to the corner sacked the knight
and this is a draw because the bishop cannot force
the king out it's a theoretical position but dude
robert what a heartbreaker man and for fedo say of
he went for it right he could have made a droid
any point but he was trying to win he blundered
with e4 while trying to win and he still could
have held but one of the things i'll say danny is
when you're well ahead on the clock sometimes you
don't even realize how much time trouble you're in
because he was up a minute for a large portion of
that game now it's a scramble and you just think
that you have more time than you have with the
increment and things go south but danny we're in
this new game here oh man we're getting another
one of these italians did we did we go back to
yesterday are we in a time travel booth here and
aronian aronian mvl called they want their opening
back i did not give maxine nearly enough crap for
that for that over and over italian but i want
to be like hey dude you're french not italian
did you get the memo and i think he would have
rolled his eyes and been like danny this is
why we don't talk anymore bad danny jokes
but uh anyway we are in an italian and we know
that jokes aside it is a very in vogue opening
at the highest levels of chess partly because of
the flexibility that robert and i talk about a
lot both sides have pawn structures that you can
do something with right it's not a symmetrical
deadlock position which is why it's so attractive
because top players want to be able to outplay
their opponent they don't want to just have forced
computer prepared draws right and i would say
that with the bishop pair in this position it's
not so clear the light square bishop which is
uh white is missing at the moment that that bishop
on g4 is going to anything other than take on f3
but even the threat of taking on f3 could
potentially be problematic for white if it
undermines the center it's not clear if that's
the case but that's just one of the things you
want to focus in on well we see carl thinking
again he's been the slightly slower player
at least in the first stages of the game
despite him being up 3-0 on the scoreboard um
i think you made a great psychological point that
sometimes the problem with being so upon the clock
is you lose that sense of urgency the guy that's
been under 20 seconds for the last 10 minutes is
very aware of how much time he has right um
and uh i hope phil save adjusts from that
all right h3 now wait speaking of undermining
uh i'm looking at a conversation jacob
uh what i guess then queen takes f6 but i've been
looking at hikara's facial expressions because
at least he knows there's something super rare hit
car knuckle board number 19. he was smiling and
looking at the ceiling it's always okay go back to
the camera just i know the catalog it's always the
the look at the opening look at the
opening i'm not actually thinking
right now but people love this normally it's
that hey car nakamura number seven that was a
what is going on here that was number
19. you rarely see that everyone you're
welcome it's funny because people when you say you
have a catalog of hikara facial expressions they
think you just you know make things up they don't
realize that you actually have a full-on book of a
car facial expression i've had i got a lot of time
on my hands a car and i've been hanging out since
we were i was 10 he was eight things got real on
the basketball court i'll tell you that um and uh
anyway c5 okay but hicaro did get the best of that
exchange no jokes and he took advantage of the d4
pressure that you called yeah c5 is a nice move
you have double pawns why not try to undouble them
challenge white center and free up some important
squares that d4 pawn goes to d5 give me that e5
square for my knight the queen of f6 also stares
at the pawn on b2 things look to be going hikaru's
way for a fourth straight game yeah playing well
bishop takes c5 um the b2 pawn is under fire
as you said so he defends it but now here comes
95 right 95 i guess there's f4 just for the time
being that does allow white to hang in here it
feels like white's position should be on the
verge of collapsing but you have to be precise and
that's why hikaru wisely spending his time plus a4
look at that we talk about the concept of
full board awareness he knows that 95 is
something he wants to play but first let's try
to open up the queen side for my rook on eight
it's a great move and even though i was teasing
earlier about a lesson that robert's working on
full board awareness it actually i love how you
say that right because that's like such a good
position to train where you're like all your
focus has been about this and you've got the
dark square attention but you take a moment
to reflect on the full board opportunity
to use your strengths everywhere right and a4
is a great move to create that kind of chance
and while it's an advanced concept i think full
board awareness is something people should develop
very early in their chess kind of careers right
yeah absolutely and that's why i try to remind
everybody including myself of different ideas in
that last game remember that the bishop doesn't
match the corner that may seem irrelevant because
there were all these other pawns on the board
but it actually played a role and that is what
happens in chess you want to sort of forecast
where the game could potentially go and make
the most of your opportunities and here look
at that move rook a5 it wasn't just about the weak
pawn he opened up the fifth rank so his rook can
just jump from a5 over to the king side and
attack the king so preemptively federer says i
don't want any part of that check i'm gonna march
my king over to f1 i'm gonna get out of josh let's
bring back the analysis board because seriously
robert is rocking the full board awareness moments
accidental teaching moments by robert hess um a4
boom and it's not just about the double pawn dude
it's about rook a5 the flexing of the full board
now you double rooks and white is just struggling
here with weaknesses you'll have to deal with
here the potential over here on the king side
i love it when you teach look at that queen e6
hitting the rook on c4 and the pawns the pawn
on h3 ouch this is a model game by hikar right
now yes he shows the problems when white plays
standard looking moves that seem like all is good
and fine and then you are met with this c5 break
that he played then he pushes a pawn up the board
yeah then he just created problems on both flanks
and fedocere's pieces were not coordinated well
enough to deal with everything and the game is not
over right here h3 falls okay it's not checkmate
at least not yet so you can continue playing here
but it's not looking good because material is now
even white's pawn structure is worth worse excuse
me with double pawns in the f file and the a file
and look at this rerouting the knight instead of
focusing on the a pawn let me bring my knight
into f4 with check your king is being hunted
no seriously and for the record i highlighted
that idea before he carl played it i saw it happen
i knew you would no kidding uh yeah the king
has got his full running shoes on right now um
notice that hiccaro not as down on time as he has
been in some of the other games in this match so
really just kind of finding his form here and
like you said it would be a shock to me this was
you know not to take anything away from artemyev
or even from hikaru the other way but i felt
like this match might be the one that was
a little closer um of the of the you know
the number one versus you know the lowest
number one and number two versus lower seats today
right but right now hikaru is like hey i heard the
cry i know people said that federal save is a
match for me but i'm bringing my a game today
he really has thus far and it's impressive because
federsev is a monster but hikaru i just i'm
noticing it in his play today he he clearly cares
and he just brought his best blitz self i i'm
really liking the way he's playing and i actually
don't think it's an overreaction you could see
the quality of the games he's not being bothered
by kind of oh this pawn i need to take that back
and he's playing very aggressively tactically and
he's not giving fedo say of many chances at all
well we've got more than 24 000 of you still
on twitch we've had a lot of viewers all day
8 000 plus of you on youtube you see all the
chat rooms being super positive super focused
on the chest we really appreciate it and uh and
thanks for being here all right rook takes a3
sacking the exchange to finish off the j.o.b
here look at that he's going to win the f2 pawn
open up the second rank and ask questions later
this is by the way he even has this move queen
e5 i'm not sure if that's the finishing touch but
you got to be thinking about it a quick flip to a1
i like it you're you're
looking everywhere he just says
i'm going to just just gotta see what
the [ __ ] no no good okay nevermind
one of those moments where yeah it looks good
let's not actually focus on it but no it's a
good idea let's say it was good it looks pretty
good to me i'll give you that but the problem for
white right now is your king is still out in
the open black's queen and brook are hitting the
f2 square uh okay so how does he gonna settle on
the draw maybe he feels like he let the attack go
nope no that was brigade the car was like
i i don't think that black can get in any danger
in the near future so there's no reason and look
what's the age was that h1 become a queen they
might notice how the geometry of the board was so
perfect the queen was guarding the only weakness
so fetishive has to exchange it and open the board
now the night blocks the e-file though i wonder
if you might consider taking yeah he does
hoping for a perpetual check
that probably doesn't exist
well rook b5 rook h5 would be checkmate but of
course black gets a move so the queen g one check
will probably there's also rook b8
just to force an exchange if you want
oh nice did you realize the que i was so focused
on not getting checkmated that i thought i need
to give you some checks to be immediate but rook
b8 that's uh a nice little move there but okay
um yeah okay queen d6 i have the same
idea i was thinking about bringing the
queen back to one of these diagonals which
is going to make it super hard for white
but he's using the fact that he's two
squares d3 and g6 so you can stop one
but not the other and the h pawn
is now free to run yeah this is a
problem howie a file problems i got him queen f1
is actually the more accurate approach because of
queen c1 you have rook a1 you have picaro finds it
now you have between a1 and rook a2 or this idea
and soon you could probably even trade off
the queens and win a rook end game but i
probably wouldn't venture into that right now yeah
he checks he'll check back on a8 no quinty wanted
to save me oh queen d wants me yeah you said it
first i give you credit not not necessarily the
cl the cleanest finish off to what was a model
game but he did finish off a model game and carl
nakamura is up four games here wow not exactly
what we were expecting um and the day is young we
have a lot of time left in this match 40 minutes
in the five minute segment but hikaru is flexing
he's playing superb chess and there are times when
hikar is the first to criticize his own play he'll
win a match by 10 games and then like oh i played
badly and sometimes you know he's just all chess
players they are trying to be perfect in their
moves but sometimes he also means it and i think
right now he's likely has to be proud of his play
i mean it's not perfect nobody plays perfect chess
but i have been very impressed by his play
and for defenders of credit he has put up
some pretty tenacious defense he just needs to
get a good position and just working it feels
like he's never really even had an advantage
in the games thus far agreed it's it's uh as
it hasn't been a single game where you felt like
a car lost control and again he's better as white
uh andrew lee in the chest tv chat
says this is better than the nba
you're darn right it is what does the
nba stand for national boring association
oh skadoosh all right oh
my goodness danny yeah yeah
my son's with the big chris paul j crowder pickups
playoffs here become phoenix suns baby um yeah i
can't say the same for my new york knicks so i'm
just gonna move on back to the chest so anyway
back to the same line we saw earlier let's
bring up the analysis board just because it's
now becoming a theoretical lesson we should
always take advantage of that if you're just
joining us hikaru employed this opening the last
time he was white we had the same moves played
until here after a6 and a4 this was different
previously fedo saif had chosen to move c5
and now we're in again a very traditional kind of
uh slav queen's gambit accepted kind of structure
this move knight a2 exposing a bishop who's kind
of lost his way now that the knight isn't pinned
and uh white does indeed pick up the
bishop pair here and has a small edge
yeah and freder for a second time has the knights
against the bishop but he has control first of the
c file but this is the problem when you're facing
bishops is look at that bishop on a3 staring down
to that pawn on d6 and the knight on d7 we talk
about superfluous pieces the knight of d7 where
does it want to go to hey maybe we'd like to go to
f6 oh wait there's already a knight on that square
so black's pieces aren't able to press forward
whereas white's initial position you already see
direct threats issue on e2 hitting a6 bishop
on a3 hitting d6 they're slicing through the
position and black is just kind of cramped and
stuck yeah yeah well set and when you have less
space as robert said your pieces are kind
of wrestling each other for the same squares
the one advantage you would say long term i
mean less space a lot of times the pawns are
solid and protecting each other but when
white also already has the bishop pair
you already have weaknesses to focus on yeah you
just feel um feel like this is going to be tough
and yeah if this continues today this is a you
know a reminder i think sometimes people see
hikaru nakamura being the streamer that he
is doing multiple tasks right he's playing
and streaming and commentating and thanking his
sponsors and modding chat right this is this is
full vintage hikaru nakamura fully focused
not streaming no commentary don't forget
why he's the two-time defending scc champion right
you know most of the time he's playing well and
even when he's streaming and doing all
these things he's still playing great chess
but this is really a different car right now yeah
and um i i feel for fedo sev because i can only
imagine how difficult it is to be his opponent
when a car is on form and right now i think this
is a position where white is better i don't see
a clean way to press forward and win the game
so if ferocious can hold here he needs something
to latch onto some semblance of confidence and
this is i think a game where if he could
survive it maybe get a win somewhere he can
try to mount a comeback even though the odds are
looking quite long yeah and here you've got this
french slash hero khan bishop you know what benny
watts said right all pawns no hope right makes uh
makes jack a dull boy over here and uh this
is why white is just clearly better now you
made a good point now now how do you convert
where's the beef hicaro's got to prove it
but the dark square dominance is real and uh
but let me ask you what's the plan here teach
me bobby hess how does white how does white make
make progress i would play queen c2 provoking g6
and then probably play queen to d2 and then try to
knight g4 and just i'm going to use both oh okay
look at how you just work that with no diggity
you brought the queen up that's what ricardo did
well f5 was the response that same idea you had
using the light squares for checkmate threats
everyone if you missed the memo now you're
undermining the defender of said square right
that was an only move quinn f7 you couldn't
move the knight and you couldn't allow knight
takes f6 to happen so queen f7 was played
95 if takes takes now you have to move the
knight allowing queen f7 plus it opens
up and puts pressure on the c file here
i mean just he he's turning a tactical position
into a also a positional one he's recognizing
it doesn't have to be about checkmate only i
can fix my isolated pawn while attacking my
opponent's knight and removing that defender but
he goes back to g4 interestingly enough he says i
you know something about the 95 offering
the trade didn't speak to a place queen d3
well and point out everyone this this move is
not just a move that allows a check it allows
checkmate full board awareness as robert has
said many times today so icaro is kind of sitting
pretty and that he can kind of play tickle he
plays this sort of just subtle what does this even
do move like a high-class waiting move because
it's good to be king when you're the dictator
of the position sit on your opponent and let them
figure it out with only two minutes on the clock
it's a good practical lesson to not feel that
you have to force things just just sit tight
and as you know you're taught repeating the
position can be a good thing when you're the side
with the advantage so icard does it once he brings
his knight back g4 slides his queen to d3 and i
guess federic plays a5 because there was no other
move that looked the least bit appealing yeah
uh but you're looking at the whole
board give me a move give me a move
a5 played but it does have drawbacks potentially
now there's new issues to worry about
you were focusing on the exact part of the board i
was also looking at and not only is there queen b5
that bishop on a3 can find its way to d6 and to c7
if the queens get traded or that queen is removed
from its defense so you have created a permanent
setup on the queen side no longer can black even
think about playing b5 that squares under white's
control and you're just adding new weaknesses
to the position the knight comes back the queen
switches over ricardo no longer interested in
repeating the knight and queen dance brings
pressure here with queen c3 to the pin knight
so a funny idea robert just white have time for
things like i know you don't i was going to say
bishop v3 bishop b5 to gang up on the pin i
forgot the knight actually defends the queen
95 is a threat actually you're gonna laugh but
that was my exact train of thought i was like
hey can white yeah that [ __ ] won't be one and
get into the game oh i think did did he forget
that too no federal state is going to take here
and trade but he carries saying the end game is
still great for me i have the bishop pair uh that
pawn on b6 and the pawn a5 those are vulnerable
pawns and the king will just quickly run into the
center for white i actually like the decision yeah
king of two a very kind of simple decision not
the flashy long diagonal checkmates we've been
envisioning but but i guess you're right i mean
the end game after queen sees oh wow he checks
there a little inner meso to try to force a bad
pawn structure but doesn't really help black
i think bishop to e7 followed by d8 is what the
doctor ordered here yeah that knight is going to
have to go to a8 to keep everything defended
which is a pretty ugly move to have to play
i don't see a breakthrough just yet like if i
see where we're going for bishop b7 bishop d8
that's all happening so king f7 bishop go go to
d8 and the knight has to retreat to the corner
like white looks amazing but what now yeah and
and black can actually kick you out next move
but there are moves like g5 you try to start
opening things on both sides of the board
icarl definitely agrees with you or he wouldn't
have paused to think okay wait he's going for all
the moves he agrees with you too and and yeah
i guess if we're just evaluating principle of
two weaknesses here everyone the problem
is white has both a two on one potential
asked pawn here you're a wizard harry and also the
target on the dark squares over here so it just
makes black's tasks so tough to defend
and white's one pawn on d4 stops black's
two pawns on e6 and d5 so the pawn advantage
of danny is highlighting for the g h file
those pawns are mobile you can play g4 h4 h5 g5
just push those pawns up can't be stopped look
at the 98 it is trapped in the corner over
there but hey is that a knight or a donkey
oh whoa there's no way to sacrifice there's no
way this can work i don't believe in it i think
it's a good practical try but i i certainly don't
believe in it yeah the king is just marching over
tired of getting grinded decides to go for a
sack but these pawns are easily stopped by the
two bishops the bishops are not like knights
when it comes to stopping past pawns everyone
they do their job and they do it
well so um the bishop pair is wait
wait wait a second what does the car just
do with he didn't bring the bishop back
i anticipated either bishop d6 or bishop c1
now he's got himself in a bit of a pickle here
it should still be winning but you you can't
ever take b3 without the queen happening so
now you got to do some weird stuff yeah that was
a bit surprising because you were saying bishop c1
and i thought that was going to be the response
just stopping the pawns before they could even
consider moving up the downside for black but
having pawn a2 is b3 is weaker but look at this
move knight c4 i don't think you can take it
yeah you can't uh for the record everyone it
takes black would take and then c3 check and the
pawns coming forward past pawns must be pushed
okay so king f6 is he is he claiming that black
can't do anything is that what we're looking for
i mean i guess you could even play like g4 and h4
that's what he's saying he's like well now what
yeah the pawns can never push right because if you
play b2 you lose a2 so that's the good news for
white even though it looks scary the king's in the
corner sorry oh no you're i wasn't looking at the
time you're right but the pawns can't push so that
means that at some point white could play bishop
b5 to a4 or something like that and try to get the
pawn yeah now it's now this should be a done deal
yeah well now he's got himself in a position too
where the bishop is guarding the diagonal as well
i thought he might play bishop
b5 there but i guess this is good
glad almost lost in time wait point seconds
a back breaker heartbreaker
oh my god that felt surprisingly good i'm like
a new man i feel like the dad in incredibles
who just got pulled apart by the robot and i
know these exact references because i've seen
both incredibles and incredibles 2 with your
family so hey when you're watching movies with
the kids at the wrenches right oh man great
time it's a great time that's a great time
um you know who's not having a great time
right now it's not over federal save oh my gosh
hikaru nakamura the beast right um he's
uh the last man who's trying to get into
the semi-finals of course this match is far from
over the winner of this will fill out our bracket
um and remember everybody it's already set mark
your calendars next weekend you're spending it
right here with these two guys hey robert
air high five wait wait wait wait wait wait
oh i mean i could do more
you know yeah i don't like
anyway so c5 car
snap oh snap browser crashed you want
to fix it everything's okay i just i
literally saw austin app on screen i'm
like ron burgundy oh snap i was like
at the same time like why are you reading
that out loud instead of fixing the problem
when i get tired ron will read whatever
you put on the teleprompter everyone
go bleep yourself just.com could you imagine
could you imagine if you could you know you
probably can't program the message you get
into an awesome app that's what you should
be so funny if you could if it said like you
know something uh santiago native chung for
old wooden ship um anyway pretty sure that's not
what was said in the movie but i appreciate you i
i stole two lines combining them together to keep
this thing pg i'm good at that um yeah all right
wow well we are doing coverage of a chess
match but danny i got to ask you something
yeah obviously hikaru was focused just on federsev
but do you think in a sense he might be sending
a message to wesley so because wesley knocked
him out in the skilling uh champions tour event
and west then went on to beat magnus that's who
the winner of this match plays in the semifinals
feels like there's a little bit
of hey yeah you know i i got this
right well i mean yeah i think kokoro you
know we know this is going to be a year
that is going to come down to the wire no idea
who's going to win you and i have said i mean
hikaru i think our unarguably has the tougher
side of the bracket he's facing wesley so who's
been in the finals against him the last two years
in the fc in the sec without magnus playing taking
nothing away from mdl who's magnus's opponent
who i do believe by the way is a stylistic
difficult opponent for magnus in some ways we'll
talk about that later i can't wait for that match
but um yeah i think i think hikaru no matter
what has just shown up today in full force and
reminded people you know he's an entertainer
when he's streaming and a great chess player
but he's also just a freak when he when he's fully
focused without the distractions of commentary and
hey this is right now he's putting on a show i
don't know what else to say he's winning again
by the way as black yeah he is and fedor does not
look very happy to be here i'm happy to be here
i'm having a great time ferocious nazi too i'm
having a great time too about to yeah i couldn't
tell if you're trying to do your seinfeld or what
was happening there you were having a great time
too if you just wanted to make your boat what go
ahead no i just never know with you if you're just
becoming you're kind of a child so i don't know
if you're going to puberty on camera right now and
your voice is cracking but either way it's fun for
fedo he is not enjoying himself on the chessboard
right now hikaru in just like honestly some of
the best shape that i've seen of him in maybe
i hate say ever but when have you seen hit car
play like this like obviously there are moments
but it's everything it's been a little
while you know it's yeah this is uh
wow this is great form for hikaru you know what
it is it's the chess.com hoodie i mean uh chest
chest bay i know you're listening you could send
a car a message say that's your good luck hoodie
buddy don't forget it um i see people using the
uh the a word in chess tv chat i do not believe
there will be an adoption i will go as far as to
say no way okay hicaro is a is a monster right now
don't even don't even whisper those words in front
of me with fedo say it he's not gonna allow it
he'll find himself although i'm not gonna lie this
doesn't look like a good start here in game six
this is no good blacks of a pawn the rooks
are for black are coordinated in open files
the rook on a2 you probably should play b3 just
to make that rook feel like it's uh a really yeah
it's useful in a way uh in the dark squares
and the king side not looking very good
you can imagine if that bishop could get
from c5 over to b8 there would be a checkmate
i don't know how i do that but i'll just
i'll pretend like that queen's not in the
way just put the bishop there exactly or
queen f if you before queen see one was
you know queen f4 bishop yeah queen of
four and bishop d6 was a threat indeed
i don't know what to say anymore
what can white hope for here that's that's where
i'm at right now let's think in terms of what we
can wish for the holidays are coming up holidays
are here uh what would you wish for hop on hop on
santa's knee here right i mean i don't know if
you're into that kind of thing or um uh no okay
i'll give you eight gifts you get
to ask for but you only get one
and then it's not even the one it's not even
the one you want you give the pre-packaged
uh gift wrap thing over there
that's like a toy i didn't want
i know how this works yeah i know how it
works g5 played uh fedo say of trying to
mix it up but you highlighted earlier
the real issue is just work on a2 um
not not not having a party whoa okay i
like this idea of g6 even just from a
practical perspective right fedex is making a mess
the issue is he wishes it were more of a mess
because he's trying to you know create a potential
target here that's the e6 pawn and i i do agree
with you though that you need to do things like
this you need to give up upon to say your knight
on d4 now has to remain there protecting e6 but i
don't think hikar is upset to keep his knight
on d4 it's such a great square but i will say
the idea with knight e4 was also to open the c3
square for the bishop rather than the knight and
that that does undermine the centralized pony
and and if this knight is traded you know i'm
just looking at the light square opportunities
for fedo say up here the long-term light square
chances so let's let's analyze bishop to c3
see what is what does cecaro have on that move
so you're clearly putting pressure on the knight
on d4 you're trying to get through that night
to the knight enough six i'm imagining at
some point some kind of e5 push but that
proves your point that if you ever play e5 the
light squares now are super vulnerable and only
white has a light square bishop so i'm starting
to to buy it a bit more well i mean black is
you know if we if we do the count black is up what
two three pawns here i mean so materially yes it's
tricky but i just feel like from a practical
perspective if we go back to when this kind of
approach started where he's like look i'm not just
going to sit tight and wait for you to figure out
my dar squares i'm going to open up some
light squares it just makes sense play
towards your strengths and okay this is a very
good move by icaru coming into f4 is a problem
yeah it's protecting g6 and e6 while attacking uh
the queen of course in the bishop one g2 so he'll
just take back on c5 with the queen i think or
dang we'll take with the pawn to keep his knight
well protected yeah take the pawn reinforce
the knight even if g6 falls you still have
knight f4 coming i mean he's thinking
about it though yeah i was going to say
because taking with the queen exposes the
rook's awkwardness because now you're like
hey dude remember that rook on a2 not
doing its normal job all day right yeah
so rook a3 finally you know i got excited
today junior get your rook in the game you know i
wasn't gonna use a billy madison reference but um
sometimes you're not gonna frown upon it
either i am frowny people just can't see it
but this rook on a3 trying to go to c3 queen c1
says not so fast take my knight on d4 have fun
with it i'll take your bishop on e1 then i'll
bring my rook down to help deliver a checkmate
yep yeah i mean just to show everybody robert's
talking about this is a wee bit of a problem note
that even defending g1 opens up a new checkmate
so the pressure is real fedo save has a mess to
figure out and you have to settle on queen e1 okay
he goes queen e4 guarding attacking overwhelming
i wish i had insightful things to say about
this position it just it doesn't feel good
for white you need five is is there moves like you
can't play knight c2 right away i assume because
we need six jack and next year but yeah the
problem is there's more pressure coming to this
you can even trade queens right you have a couple
pawns yeah you could even knight f5 by the way
because if you take c1 i take and the
knight guards e3 and if knight f5 takes
e6 i put the king on h7 and still got problems
um agreed a queen b2 i guess uh overthinking it
well knight five works i mean queen
e6 is just one pawn the king is
very safe on h7 yeah he pushes the e5 great
move as well but again all points made aside
we are now in mutual time pressure you
got to give federal save credit for that
but it's been a mess we'll see if he can take
advantage of it you know it's funny we love
our bishops but white would could really
use a knight on g5 right about it yeah
the king on h7 how do you attack that king
unless you have a knight there's just no way
it's like the the brick house what happened to
the big bad wolf when he ran into that brother
like man engineering can't take down that brick
house no sir okay so queen b3 hitting a4 hitting
the bishop queen takes a force threatens
queen episode munching it's just it's wrong
well if it's wrong icard doesn't want
to be right oh you are you are saying it
true sir oh my gosh he's gonna take on a1
he's my rook c1 check to trade everything off
oh well
six wins out of the gate for the number one
seed and defending champion hickory nakamura
maybe he watched enough of the magnus match
and he was like enough is enough here i come um
this is shocking i'm shocked i'm legit shocked
and it's not that we don't know hikaru's capable
of this but we also know how great fedo save is
and you remember what fedo said did to ferugia
who uh let me remind you never led in
that match right trailed the whole way
that's how dominant fiddle save was even
though it went to overtime even there he
never quite let his guard down but here he
is running up against the train of nakamura
just i don't even know what to say uh this
is beyond impressive and for fedo say of
they've had recent blitz matches of probably
around 20 games where federal save actually
came out on top so it is possible for fedocere
to take down hikaru as strong as zekaro is
and while hikara knows that he came well
prepared he's playing these positions that sort
of minimize the risk for himself and i i have
noticed that i mean look at this opening here
black's piece is pretty cramped even if black is
able to stabilize and ensure that he's not so much
worse is he really ever going to be better
and the answer doesn't really look like yes
yeah i mean i talk about i feel like every time
you and i are here i tend to take the defensive
position of the structure and say yeah but it's
solid and yeah but you can liberate your pieces
eventually but hikaru knows these systems so well
i feel like at this point i've been seeing enough
of hikaru on the white side of this that you know
if i was an ambitious chess player i'd review the
games and take more notes because i know this
is blitz chess but these are you know the most
money we've ever had on the line the evolution of
online chess has been very real over the last few
years and we know these these games make it into
chess space right twick gathers them and these
guys these games are studied and these guys often
don't hold back their prep so yeah i mean hicaro
just kind of knows what he's doing here and he's
always well prepared on the white side of the qgd
he is although fedor sayev in game one he was
able to neutralize hikaru for quite a while
and he played bishop b7 rook c8 rook c7 kind of
doubled up his rooks in the c file and eventually
broke with the move c5 i would say a difference
in this game compared to that is that black's
pawn is on a5 which means that if you ever play c5
for black the b5 square is permanently whites for
the taking so that's an important note that if you
have pawns two squares away from one another the
square between is often for your opponent and
you're just seeing control of it yeah you said
it well even though black's mission is solid
it's also passive and so it's like the dreams
are bishop b7 and get the rook over right
and and then what right and why is debating
uh between the same themes you highlighted when
we first had this opening do i go for e4 and try
to flex with the pawns in space or do i leave that
square open for for flexible ideas like knight e4
that that opened the c file i will say one thing
in fedo say of defense a5 prevents icaru's idea
remember from that game where bishop a6 was played
to eliminate this bishop and attack the weak pawn
so notice notice that cardo changes gears and goes
for this idea instead and i would immediately play
bishop f4 for black uh there's some risk of a move
like that because the bishop just attacks the rook
oh let's go to the analysis board analyze
because i think my partner was right on that
right on the money i think black had to
play the move bishop f4 right when it was
played the computer agrees with you man the rook
moves and now you can strive for your c5 moves
the rook is on the queen is there
even ah there's no nice c5 stuff
and the best part about it is just that your
bishop isn't getting caught behind the pawns
so i don't know if it's actually
that good i'm you know worried that
the bishop gets some trouble but i don't like the
current game position where the bishop is now yeah
sorry i was just analyzing [ __ ] before it was a
great move but you like you said the current game
situation with bishop b7 you notice how quickly
hiccaro played e5 he didn't have to be asked
twice to block off that move that probably fedo
said should have played and now hikaru is taking
advantage of the b5 square as you prophesized this
is no fun and also the bishop on c7 look at it
it's staring to e5 which is defended for the time
being uh end right it's it's pinned it's weak um
you can take on c5 if you want to ruin black's
pawn structure on that side of the board
it's just not a fun position for fedo sev and
we've said that before unfortunately for him
and this is one of those things where
now it's like the momentum right i mean
we know how good fredo seave is but
the momentum here it's like now he's
now you start fighting your own head right
because you've lost six in a row right and
i'm going to add another chest point here that i
keep talking about bishop versus knight dynamic
if black is stuck with this bishop on b8 good
luck to your light squares on the queen side
and i think that's part of the reason why photos
have just went bishop a6 saying hey i'm going to
challenge your knight and maybe capture it at some
moment so that your knight can't just dominate my
bishop on b8 and he does just this the compromise
um or the concession if you will of doing such is
that you give away the light squares permanently
so now hicaro has a new square for business will
he try to use the knight tactically there's the
e5 pawn and the and the h4 pawn to worry about
but even if you don't go that way although
actually the more i look at it look how awkward
this is the queen is trying to guard maybe
too many things just for example if you take
black can even maybe take here and then take
here and e5 falls in the end and h4 falls so
actually hikaru xc8 whoa look at that he was
laughing in the face of the queen for good reason
right and not the first time today that he's
been willing to give up screening for some rooks
and danny you could take h4 you could take
e5 have fun with those pawns the knight
comes into c6 and b6 is also a problem you
wish that pawn can go back to a7 for black
so that b6 isn't hanging and it's just
a nice square for the knight even if
the pawn were not hanging but it is
on b6 and this is just problematic
i mean it just i seriously feel for vladimir
because i know what it's like to feel like i
didn't do anything wrong i'm just playing the
normal stuff but then you start not you don't
trust yourself anymore you're like i've lost
all these games i need to change something up
i need to play a different opening i
need to play more aggressively because
my strategic more passive play isn't working out
but my tactical play is not working out either
hikaru nakamura is just a card nakamura at
the end of the day i don't even know why
that's bad but oh wait g3 running out of squares
uh-huh queen's running i i just had a feeling
you know what happens when i get that
feeling it's a chess you will feel
well 97 check is winning a rook so i hope you
enjoyed it wow the queen cannot touch these
squares and so she runs to that side of the board
97 picks up the rook for free omg and or snaps
if you got the emote use it omg's
are snaps is what i just said
we've had a lot of subscribers today thank you
for the support i'm going to go ahead and use my
omg's or snaps unless you want me to hescasm
are you in the mood for a hess gasmess
it's probably the most inappropriate and weirdest
thing you could ask me uh on stream but you know
i guess if there's a time for it a car being
up seven to nothing maybe that's the time
okay we'll just do we'll do omgs or snaps
instead there we go dark side beat me to it
um there it is just come on jesus snaps
at least you know how to get the chat riled up
daddy yeah we got 28 000 of them on twitch 8 500
on youtube this is the most viewers we've had all
day um and uh we think thank you for being here um
oh the italian right back in all italian but this
is not quite the italian we saw yesterday because
uh unlike those games ferocious was able to push
his pawn to b4 because a5 was played only after
b4 was played so a bit of a different setup
we did see hikaru play one really nice game
when white overextended and then he was playing
on both sides of the board but i think this is
a good choice by vladimir considering the score
considering his mindset i i feel like his position
for now is quite solid okay yeah it's flexible
right good choice maybe give cecaro ideas of
overextending if you're not careful with the
lawn chain um the car taking his time here
getting a little bit down on the clock
he looks troubled what face is this
what what face was that what a car sorry i
was actually looking at the chest and not
hikaru i'm sorry i missed oh there we
wait hold on that's not number 19 nor
number seven what is that dude give it to me
again buddy come on in carl throw me the face
it was an open mouth gate it's very it's very rare
in a wild hikaru his own natural habitat
where you get to add a new face to the catalog
so what number is that now i don't know i
don't know i didn't see it long enough okay
world's leading expert means i
also have to humbly admit when i
don't know what i'm talking about okay
even if i do know his faces very well
um i do like this transition he's trying to
force the iqp or this pawn will be a target um
white has the ideas of 949c5 though yeah that'll
save playing well if he can find a way to make
something of this italian he's got an advantage
maybe for the first time today yeah 94 is a
good move because uh if black does not take on d5
perhaps white will be able to keep that extra pawn
this isn't really a very good pawn but if you're
not winning it back i'll gladly keep that one
and your 94 also can go to c5 in the future that
was my idea let's analyze it real quick and uh see
what see what he's thinking about why not knight
e4 i like it you like it if it takes we have two
ideas robert nice c5 but you can also play the
knight to e5 right and there's just this like
you know this x-ray vision you're worried about
on f7 as we said the knight is also coming to c5
95 played immediately similar ideas i expect
94 to come here soon and indeed it does
yeah you said x-ray vision i'm just worried
about my regular vision so i don't know
hope we can get that behind us if you know what
i mean hindsight let's hope it's 20 20 soon
knight c5 well perfect prediction
danny you you had this all
mapped out in hikara's face
that is not a happy hikaru
yeah he's uh wishes he could make
like taylor swift and shake this
one off but i think fedor says says
i'm not getting adopted today buddy
all right no knight takes e6 i would take that
bishop and then go after the light squares we just
saw hikaru use the light squares in a
previous game right going for checkmates
on the king side here the e6 pawn the g6
square if that bishop can go from c4 to uh
a2 g8 diagonal to go to the b1 h7 diagonal there
may be some mating opportunities as well yep
27 kind of forced to defend e6 but there's there's
still bishop a3 with tempo and knight c5 there's
also maybe simple moves right kind of sit tight
on the position sometimes i like moves like g3
to hold f4 and just like queen e2 bring the
rook over white is white is definitely better
also up on the clock for the sake of mercy
you have to root for fedo save in this game
bishop c5 just run out i like it bring
that piece in the bishop on b2 wasn't
doing anything so at least on c5 it offers
the trade while keeping before safe and sound
and i by the way i did like your idea with g3 not
now probably but g3 was a good move just to give
the kid oh my gosh rookie two i like that yeah
that's a move to make the battery work for you
put the rook in front of the queen where
the battery is often most effective
i really like that um wait a second there's got
to be some kind of tactics here i got e5 i've
got b6 where's the beef a5 is also hanging in
some of these lines also at target maybe it's
as simple as that robert capture once you have
to take this way because of the pin capture b6
and win a5 with tempo in fact i might have just
called the combo indeed here we go there it is
so an extra pawn a french-like pawn structure
for black with this e6 pawn being a weakness
and plenty of time for fredo save this has been
a good game by him and really the first one so
far that we've seen you know 30 moves deep
where he can claim that he has an advantage
yeah no seriously uh he's played very well
in this game start to finish and if you're
a federal save fan you're like go back to this
go back to this opening go back to this approach
been very clean now we're assuming he converts
we know that hikaru like magnus is very good
at persevering and defending bad positions so
i'm not claiming victory for
white just yet that's all
i just black doesn't really have any ideas
which is the sad part knight f4 is a big
threat and that's why g3 gives the king space so
there's no background checkmates to worry about
but also gives the knight this important f4 square
to attack e6 and win the e6 pawn directly so
i think that hikaru might have to try knight
d6 to put them then e4 blocking the file but
then it can only last for so long eventually
white just taken over there yeah moving the knight
allows the e5 square to be open for business so
has his defensive work cut out for him we'll see
if he can hold an aggressive move attacking the
knight asking if it'll save what he intends to
do with it i think you'd like the major piece
end game if 95 hikaru might might trade bring
the queen in to maybe e3 or c2 or something and
we'll see because the problem is e6 also hangs but
my point is do we think the major piece end game
improves to carl's drawing chances i guess he does
he might have felt like he has no choice i
think that he's feeling like he's he hates
his position you saw that face i
don't know what number it is but
and here comes f5 now that's a truly frustrated
nod not the uh the confident not that's a hikaru
nakamura number five not to be confused with
the mambo number five i knew you're gonna say
exactly that i thought about beating
you to the punch and i was like nope
can't say it couldn't bring it i'm gonna let
him do it i'll give you a chance to complete my
later your sandwiches rook c8 now look at this
plain tickle on both sides of the board is where
it's at that's what the cool kids do now h4h5 oh i
wanted it on h4h5 keep the brooks on the board bro
he's not going to keep the rooks in the
board because the rookless position he
will try to give himself this outside pass
pawn on the queen side he is up one but h4 now
is a good move i think actually you can still
go h4 h5 okay actually didn't go anywhere
h4 h5 are you saying i guess the problem is
if h4 you maybe run into h5 right so that's
probably what he's thinking about i don't
actually maybe want him to blockade that way
but i'll say i'm gonna take a second
play slow oh queens look at that move forces
the c file to be owned by black uh we may
have spoken too soon about start to finish for
fedocere because yeah this doesn't look so easy
i think a car will play h5 and indeed
he does he's just going to try to hold
there's a candy cart yeah i was going to say queen
c1 yeah just bringing the queen in what no i was
going to say just bring the queen in and i could
actually see a world where black wins this game
if white tries crazy to say that you shush
your mouth when you're talking to me don't
you don't you say that don't you [ __ ] should
say that by the way only 40 seconds left let's
remind you that at the break we will have another
prime time smackdown for all of our subscribers
the rest of you will enjoy the sweet sounds of a
commercial for a product you're never going to buy
but subscribe now throw us your prime uh i don't
even know who it is we're gonna find out i think
it's danny wrench versus daniel daraditsky let's
just say that spoilers and upsets happen um do
you just refer to yourself by your name without
saying you know i played it's been a long day
oh no did you just say you saw a world where
black wins this game i told you to shut your mouth
i'm laughing at you not at anything else
you okay over there danny oh wow
queenie one check queen takes a5 coming
with tempo and black is going to win this
game you know what lesson learned
i'm going to shush my mouth when i
speak you are going to shush your
mouth when you're talking to me
oh man poor plato mirror and you see a car shaking
his head he doesn't feel good about it either okay
he doesn't feel good about it either um
wow seriously yeah no i mean the thing about
d7 matches especially when um you know people
are enjoying themselves you know in the chat i
think hikaru has you know we're saying he's a lot
of respect for fidosev obviously and he kind of
knows right that he didn't deserve this game from
he didn't play his best chess let's put that right
but he also knows that what happens when you start
winning all your games if somebody doesn't
get a win people in the chat start talking
and i think he feels for fedo say because he knows
how good of a player vladimir no it's totally true
and it's the same reason why you know magnus
kind of laughed and you know shook his head
when he won some games against artemia that you
know shocked the world hashtag knight versus
queen we should have started a hashtag knight
vs queen um i assume you saw that game yeah but
it'd be like the least successful hashtag of
all time okay well i've started a few of those
of the least successful hashtags ever
look at this white might even get mated
yeah i'm not doing this anymore
no i'm kidding but seriously this is jokes aside
don't let the results fool you fedo save is an
absolute freak and uh this is this is shocking
again hicaro clearly wanted to send a message
make a statement bring his a game insert overblown
sports cliche robber but what can you say about
8-0 after five minutes we've never seen this have
we you know i could say it's a chess match out
there i mean if both coaches think it's several
steps ahead sometimes it feels like there's a
stalemate between the players but then oh they
overcome the odds and win but in all seriousness
danny hikaru nakamura is playing one of the finest
matches i've ever seen and this is a guy who went
toe-to-toe with magnus carlson all this pandemic
and he is just came out of the gates really just
in fine form precise chess never giving fedor
say of positions he was quite comfortable with
until this game and this is just the type of day
it is for a car that even in his worst it's still
right now out playing fetuses best and it's just
a big issue for vlad hill will win some games
going forward but hikaru nakamura should be very
proud of the match he's played thus far well said
nothing more to add thank you to our subscribers
enjoy this prime time smackdown at the break and
robert hess and i will be right back with the 3-1
segment in today's speed chess championship match
dania how do you get your hair to stay
so curly i mean how many times you get
a perma day you're not going to talk how many
times only once actually i don't use anything
any special condition or nothing really uh
nothing no it's just it's just the way that
i am and i'll deal even my hair will be look
even better when i'm finished thrashing you
whatever i didn't even wear my chest.com
shirt for you today but i did almost put
my western invitational chest camp shirt on which
is funny i went with vulcan but i see you wearing
the chess camp shirt that you and i taught at
together the last time i was holding you while
you were crying after having way too many of these
remember that way too many uh you were holding me
i see i remembered it a little bit differently
no no okay but in uh in life like chess your big
brother's always here for you when i give
you a spanking that shocks the world okay
actually i don't know just in a nice
place here we go you've given me
exactly one spanking and i'll give
you that at the world open thousand
nine and i mentioned you could do
this dating don't hyperventilate
man this is a very good game danny all
right let's get this party under so yeah
you did that once okay i give you that never again
i have the experience of losing to danny wrench
once that was the first and the last time
that's what they all say oh yeah that's what
they all say they all say that they all say it
e5 that was a great move man where did you learn
this theory i i need to put pick that book up
danny wrench's guide to the opening i know you're
being sarcastic and i don't appreciate it dude
i'm never sarcastic what are you talking about man
i'm always really nice to you danny yeah give me a
point i am worse here i i apprecia i accept that
but i play word i play better and now in worse
position so that was all deliberate yeah all part
of the campaign you and bartholomew have a lot of
cloning like that oh yeah i try to hang out with
the cool people when i teach in arizona all right
fine we'll go into the end game i'm crushing
you i'm playing so well right now i'm so proud
all right it's time to get serious though no you
are actually playing pretty well but i'm just
waiting for that to end i just want to be around
here there's the blunder there's the blunder
wait am i up with these oh
daniel
oh wait a minute i didn't you believe me for a
second oh crap how did i not get a queen out of
that that was hardly even fair should have
played the queen's gambit oh jesus that was
so awkward and so good i love you that was amazing
man hey why don't you promote i'm gonna check
i get zero points for that for the thrashing
of like the greatest bullet player in the world
ah the greatest bullet player in the world
will someone clip that um he just said that
and uh with this kind of performance you wonder
how hikaru nakamura might do against himself
ikarubot on chess.com because he's playing like
a machine right now an absolute accurate freak
and just uh putting on a show and uh we'll see
everyone tomorrow on december 4th for the bot
battles i'll be streaming on my own channel
we'll have commentary on the main channel
as well along with dozens of other streamers i
believe we have almost 100 streamers ready to
play with tons of cash prizes going to be a blast
robert what can we say about this 8-0 performance
which i believe is the first time in history
someone has been blanked in the 5-0 portion
there's not really much that can be said hikaru
nakamura plays one of the best segments of chess
you've ever seen from him he was lights out from
start to finish he just was getting the types of
positions that he thrives in as early as game two
i was saying how i loved his decision making he
went for a tactical position that he saw through
better than feather save did and for fedo say
it's really hard when you start losing
one game the second game you're in your
own mindset like i i know hikar is the favorite
everybody knows that but i can do this and then
trying to encourage yourself becomes increasingly
difficult the more games that you lose uh you said
it well and now the question is what can he do in
the 3-1 segment right it's a faster time control
a new day so if you were in fedor saves corner you
know at this point you're not even thinking about
a comeback right you're thinking about like the
next game right quite literally just focus on the
next game one move at a time get yourself on the
scoreboard and figure out you know the probability
that you could ever come back later right that's
not even your problem at this point and it sounds
silly but when it comes to competitors that's why
you hear coaches and sports talk talk about that
all the time because sometimes all you can do is
focus on what you can control not the scoreboard
and that would be exactly what fedo said
should do right now is focus on the next game
which we'll be starting in just seconds we will
have liftoff here and uh right on cue there we go
you know how you ask if you're somebody's coach
what do you tell them frankly i don't know what
i would have told vladimir in that break and
that's just to say that he's not playing poorly
there were a couple games where he just did
some things that he knows were not good and
it's because he's frustrated but for the most part
he's been playing quite well it just feels like
in some critical moments hikaru is getting the
upper hand and at a certain point you just have
to acknowledge that the opponent you're facing is
that good and at his best you're not going to be
able to match him it's kind of what you're saying
going forward here right just try to get a couple
points stop the bleeding i don't think that this
opening is necessarily a good choice to stop it
but you took the words out of my mouth i was
just about to say this is the this is the road
to adoption and i hate to use that word i said i
wouldn't use it i called out shaft for saying it
but now you're down 8-0 and this is a tilt opening
and the main reason we said everyone is you're you
know it's big center and all kinds of ways to make
it work tactically there's already ideas with e6
being punched through uh the knights are coming
into these squares over here with the bishop
it's this is it's not your main opening and it's
not an opening you should play when you're on tilt
as hard as that is to say right we've been
in fedo say of shoes easier said than done
but i'm not a fan of the approach no certainly
not either and one of the major issues here is
black will regain this pawn c5 but white can play
bishop e3 make sure that black doesn't get this d4
move in because the bishop on b7 is actually not a
very good piece and yes it reminds us of a french
i i always make fun of the french but
this actually is quite like a french
and even worse than a french your knight
is on h6 so unless that knight can somehow
find its way back towards the middle
of the board it's a piece that's not
helping you out and white can also consider
the move a5 here in addition to bishop e3
cementing the pawn structure on the queen side
and leaving the opponent b4 out in the wild
all the things you said are true and i'm
sitting here wondering whether f5 is about
to be punched in and i wondered if
f5 could have been played before
that is the danny way to play the position right
back sack and lose by checkmate to your opponent
um but you know but i think f5 is coming
no g he's not going he's playing super
positional here which has its merit based on
the long-term negative effects of the bishop but
i'm gonna say in a rare case i think i was right
about that one i feel like f5 was possible before
black fix things because now
the c file and the light squares
are not as bad as they were you see the eval
bar has gone much closer to equal as well
yeah i think that the position from an objective
standpoint with the evaluation bar you don't have
the moves going on for us it probably says that
it should be okay for black but again let me ask
you danny three moves go three moves go can i
improve my position no but i can make it worse
no it's true like again we say that a lot of
everyone when we do the three-move exercise
this is coaching advice from danny and
robert it's not that you imagine oh if
i had three moves i'd take take and take right
well obviously you would everybody would okay
that's not the exercise the exercise is three
usually non-capture moves what would you do
it's like you say things like rook b8 bishop c4
and i can't make a move that improves it right
you say like f6 to change the pawn structure but
i can't do that so the point robert's making is
how do you fix the position with even like your
best three moves robert would be like knight g8
97 and rook b8 those are that's my answer right
and i think you'd probably agree but the problem
is even that means black is just still clearly
worse right and those actually are a very good
suggestion maybe that's what you need to do but
that's why hikaru played c3 was to open up the
position in favor of ways for him and the a5 pawn
now becomes a target and if brook takes c8 queen
takes a 5 certainly can be played you'll snag that
pawn and it's good for white so and bishop takes
black's pieces are going backwards this knight on
d4 is such an amazing piece it blockades blocks
past pawn and you shouldn't think of this position
as being even material how you should think of it
is well yes we have the same number of pieces but
white has a two on one majority on the queen side
and black has an extra pawn from the d through
the h file white has control over the c file
black's pieces are more passive the knight on g8
f8 bishop on c8 rook on eight your pieces are all
in the last rank white's pieces are a bit more
active so everything in this position seems to
favor white and that's why danny and i are saying
that white's position is just clearly favorable
yeah and again the battery created
here really nice threatens rook
c7 and even rook c8 is not a move you can play
i think because he can just trade everything and
put a knight on c6 yeah and the pawn on a5 is
going to fall man as you said this night here
not quite a horse more than a horse of course
it's a unicorn a rare shout out to chess tv emotes
rarely does chess tv get to use emotes that twitch
doesn't have let me find it where's the unicorn
where's the unicorn i've already told you this
danny but you should watch the show the unicorn
i don't even know what you're talking
about but i just i feel like you'd be
you'd be a walton goggins fan just by
his sense of humor i'm serious unicorn
you're not gonna that you know i missed the
reference say it again i'm sorry i don't like to
you should watch the show the
unicorn i think you'd enjoy it
really yeah this is this legitimate you know
friend to friend hey we can do this later you know
we're not commenting dress but i'm just letting
you know that i think you'd enjoy it i appreciate
that no seriously um you know i've been looking
for a new show to watch when i have any time
the best person i met this year was ted lasso
right love that guy oh boy um you you know you're
a very busy guy we know all right queen d6 oh my
god that's a that's an annoying move cutting off
the communication of the defense of the knight
you can't trade because the d-pawn will run
and now he's just gonna play knight c6 and no
no that would lose the knight yeah but he'll
take on b4 and then use the a pawn now
the a pawn is running nice little passer
what's stopping you from
just using the a pawn here
he didn't push the last move maybe he could have
did you see his reaction he was mad at himself
yeah why didn't i do that why didn't i play a5
no i mean now you let the king catch it like yeah
that's that's icaro's least favorite
face number 21. i agree with danny
he hates that one but seven there's d4 yeah and
actually fiddle save is barely holding on wait
now you can oh what oh my gosh fetter save got one
and look oh my god that was a blunder by hikaru
yeah okay we could have a turnaround the adoption
may not happen it happens in in an awkward fashion
the first time we've seen hikaro blunder all day
for sure and actually the evaluation bar it swung
heavily in fedocero's favor but now it's back to
level so there clearly was a moment there missed
by fedo sayo yeah i wonder what it was i'll have
to we'll let the game finish and we'll bring up
the analysis board at the start of the next one
because i'm sure it's instructive where black had
the wind is he just going to take the draw yeah
i think so you might know he's like like so bad
that it does sound like a car i'm so it's what he
just said i read his lips he said so i'm so bad
because oh man oh man is the adoption
back on oh no oh no oh no no vladimir
you know what's funny though danny is that
immediately car went right back into wait
there's so much more chest to be played
right that that god and he goes fully
focused and he's only got five seconds
this is so hard to hold so knight east
knight d6 no you play 96 first because knight
takes e6 guards c7 and then you have a queen
yeah oh my gosh king c6 okay knight d4 also
looks good pawn in the game would be winning
so 11 seconds a car has time to figure this one
out he pushes the pawn through now he'll go to f5
i think and does the knight cap catch the pawn
if he oh my gosh no moves are black he's using
zug's one because the knight is frozen no he's
not stalemating he gets it with check oh my gosh
on freaking believable hikaru's like i
don't know what to tell you like oh my gosh
okay back to the analysis board what just
happened first of all i want to figure out
where was fedo say of winning
right it was it was here
before this whole deep uh night knight takes
should have taken with the king i guess
now i think knight takes was fine but judging
by the fact that king d5 was the wrong move he
probably brought knight to c3 first that's my
guess ah knight to c3 to offer the trade first
okay this makes a big difference and if the
knight goes to f6 you can maybe go even to
d5 and offer the trade again your knight
kind of works around to maybe hit this pawn
well f4 was hanging there too okay so knight d5 is
a real problem yep wow okay so he doesn't do that
ping d5 is a huge mistake and somehow the
hikaru gets the perpetual that by the way
i don't say it wasn't happy at a certain
point though which is what we criticized
the opening being itself at a certain point
shouldn't fedele say if just take the draw
right just get on the board and stop the
bleeding so at that point you're kind of
doing it to yourself right with king c6
yeah although you know if he wants to
yeah for fedor save right if we go back to the
live uh the new game just so we can uh catch up
with everybody and the board but for fedo save
i don't know if he actually cares about losing
10 games zero i know the online sphere makes a
big deal of being adopted this and that right
i've been adopted by a car nakamura no shame
in that i've been adopted by yonda palmashi
i'm not sure if fedocide actually cares about all
that stuff he wants to win the match and if he's
going to win the match he needs to start winning
games so he said hey a drawing at this point is
the same as a loss let me just try something and
hope that i can somehow sneak in a victory but
i don't disagree but also like you know how
it is when you're like beating yourself right
it's hard to overcome the psychological aspects
of that and just getting on the board there's
a reason why a lot of coaches will say look if
you've lost two in a row in a closed event you
play like a forcing line in the net i mean
you try to like psychologically get a point
that is not a a zero right and it's advice
that a lot of people give just for those
human psychology reason so i i agree with you
and obviously a draw doesn't change that we
would have said you know hikaru nakamura is on
his way to winning the match just i just feel
like because here's the thing dude was king
c6 really creating winning chances like zero
right like it was it wasn't like a dynamic affair
where we're like complimenting the dragon right
you know it was just one of those positions
where uh that's all your heart goes out to him
yeah and i see the chats all riled up about the
adoption and all this and that uh just you know i
i think the point that i'm making is true i really
don't think that vladimir losing eight games in a
row is just as painful for him as losing nine or
ten the number is still going to bother him at the
end of the day but uh you know i do hope that chat
has fun that's what we're here for a good time
it is a thing that people report and frankly it
is a thing that nobody would have said coming into
this match right so we do have to say that but
but again and and you know what robert's saying
is true about federal sales mindset i just think
that at a certain point you take a draw there
because because playing for uh anything else was
literally playing for a loss there there were no
other chances although i will say this he did
have the idea of the knight coming around maybe
he overestimated the whole uh you know the way the
knight remaneuvered to e2 and and with the h4 move
but all right enough is enough we're on to the
next minute game hikaru is in a dominant position
yep you're in the board over there i'm on a
dominant board spot um i wonder if i can fix this
chrome feature that makes the never mind um the
bishop is better than the knight with the pawns
on both sides of the board that was the thing i
was going to highlight in the dominant position
also there are no pawns to uh attack with this
light square bishop so even though black is up
two pawns you have these double isolated
c pawns in apon that's isolated as well
so actually creating a password from here
is not so easy but knight takes d5 it's a
critical question for vladimir can he take
this bishop and then run his king in first
i'm guessing the answer is no and the answer must
be no but it is an awkward king upon ending that
you would ever even be questioning that you
could go into down a pawn but it's that tricky
right and black can give up c7 and bring the
king to f5 and run the kingdom calculating all
this i'm watching him calculate he's doing the
finger pointing calculations doing the finger
is his point yeah the h pawn is faster it's
faster than the b-pawn yeah so so i mean we're
going to see it all happen i don't even need
to say anything right here comes no it's not
i don't think it is
fedo sam's calculation is accurate
checks out we're both going to get queens
white's going to get f5 check at the end only
hicaro can win the game but will federal save
draw and hold off adoption he snuck in
f5 first that was really smart oh what a
sweet move that was no no he's not going
to win no okay sorry i i for a second i
thought he was queening with chuck with the
pawn still on h2 but no it's still a draw
but that is so instructive and the reason why i
mean we would have to bring up an analysis board
to yeah we're going to as soon as the results in
and we officially escape the 10 and a result um
hicary was going to laugh it off for a second well
let's go to the analysis board now to the batcave
let robert instruct on why f5 was such a crucial
idea before um sorry i'm going going back uh
but wait i mean the last game yeah you're
in the wrong game i'm sorry i switched games
five right here um so instead of playing f5
let's say we uh right instead of pausing b5
just yeah just promote for both sides right and
you see the evaluation go and the reason why
is that after queening f5 check for
white king g4 queen a1 check is important
exactly what's so funny is that if i had to guess
dude okay the game ends in a draw we do not have
adoption i'm going to keep analyzing this as the
next one begins if i had to guess knowing how
well we know hikaru and what he's capable of if i
had to guess when hikaro was calculating king f5
he saw this idea of checking on a1 and trading
queens and that he would win the end game and
what he missed was the move order of f5 first and
i believe that explains partly his reaction of
laughing is that it wasn't b4 and just upon race
was that fedo say have actually found the right
move order and played the move f5 before b5 making
the queen with check and literally saving adoption
in the process carl also was pre-moving by the
way not that it would have made a difference but
i think he was pre-moving at that point so he
might not have been expecting f5 at that moment
or he probably seen it at this point but still
it just came at the right time for fedocef yeah a
really instructive idea shows you that move orders
matter and again just to highlight robert's point
if you go for this that was such an instructive
thing that i think probably hicaro had calculated
just to show the key point is again
in this line now you lose never forget
when you analyze end games everyone don't stop
in your head where both sides get a queen you
always have to go to the first sides delivering
their checks and seeing what they're capable
of are they capable of some sort of tactic
that either wins the queen or trades queens
we see a lot of end games lost at the low levels
where people stop their calculation at the queen
instead of all the way to the end right right and
it's good just try to calculate that one step more
very difficult to do uh fedor sayev he managed to
make it work he's not making this position work
though i'm gonna be honest with you danny he's
down a clean pawn he's knights are all sorts
of awkward on a6 and c7 and look at hicara's
knight jumping right into the juicy d6 square
so another one i think kikaro is taking here well
it would not be 10 in a row those rooting for it
did not get what they wanted i for one was not
rooting for it because you know mercy that's why
um and uh but yeah hikaru is right back at it
looks like he's gonna get another victory here
he won a clean pawn and now he's dominating
the middle of the board to go along with it
for sure the 1986 particularly useless over
there it's uh can't move it's not only good
square to begin with and white up a pawn can
pick from many different good moves i would say
uh rook d2 looks good g3 of course
protects f4 uh with a pawn i
i don't say danny i don't have too many words
here yeah it's a super tough position um
someone in chat just said why is vladimir
not playing his normal openings and i
you know i don't disagree that you know it's
one of the reasons we criticized that game
um you shouldn't have lost in the end but the
game he ultimately lost uh as black that was
number nine you know it's hard sometimes when
when you're when you're in a position like this
it's very difficult to get a hold of yourself and
even for the best players the tilt can be real and
in this case we we're seeing exactly what it can
what it can do to someone when we know hikaru is
not you know normally going to win a match against
fedo say of like this but at the same time you
know he's a beast and this is what he's capable
of if he gets on a roll and fedo save is having
a trouble a lot of trouble gathering himself
yeah and with the prize fund the way it is danny
right where you the winner gets i think three
thousand dollars in this round and then the
remaining three thousand dollars is split by win
percentage yep i think fetishes winning not a lot
of money right now as of this moment he's won
200 or maybe not even maybe 150 for the draw um
the point is every result is important for him
well it also is a point why he should continue to
fight and come back right i mean he doesn't want
to waste a three and a half four hour effort with
you know going home with a with a
handshake and a couple bucks he'd like to
like to get you know into the four figures get
a thousand bucks even if ricardo takes five
um and if we're being serious i mean yes of course
these players uh you know they appreciate the
generous prize fund offered but i think ultimately
what federer said wants to do is just win some
games because he know he can and chess right
now he's focusing less on his wallet and more on
how can i play my best chess because i know that
i can take some games from hikar nakamura for sure
so this position actually looks nice for white
you have the bishop pair yeah we saw the way
the other italian yeah sorry go ahead no i was
about to say the same thing we saw him working
a position similar to this he ended up getting
an isolated pawn and played well in that one
before things went south but here it looks like
weiss pieces are in perfect position but danny on
the flip side where's the real weakness for black
everything seems pretty solid for the time being
yeah it's hard because all the
tension surrounds this right you
you know those positions you tell beginners
you get to make all your moves in the opening
centralize your brooks develop your bishops
this is like almost one of those dream positions
but now what do you do with it
ikaru has over defended the e5 pawn
it's actually a very good question like okay he
played bishop d3 interesting he's defending e4 the
pawn was attacked three times if you think about
e takes d4 on the consequence so he felt the need
to protect he plays g3 pawn three squares away
from knight dominates that knight so the knight
on g6 loses its forward progress can't get to
f4 now and i i like white's position but look at
hikaru's move came to h e he's saying do something
how are you going to improve on an aesthetically
pleasing position into an actual advantage so he
just says king king she's gonna play king j8 now
okay but he put knight five my bad he went for a
little more knight of four being a threat i guess
you good there you go you're like super focused
like trying to figure out super focused on the
chess section um and i'm not super thrilled
with where the position is headed for fedo save
our defending uh slightly worse position in the
italian yet again and now it's unclear although
you know you do still like white's chances if you
get the couple pawns up and the bishop pair are
still capable of monstrous things on the diagonals
but this is better than it was earlier for black
yeah you actually have some active counter play
you're staring at this pawn e4 your bishop on b6
has new life on the diagonal you know f4 is an
obvious idea and it was just played for white
but that creates some weaknesses of its own right
the e4 pawn can no longer be defended with a pawn
because you can't go f2 to f3 the pawns push too
far and g3 becomes a bit loose look for sacrifices
on that square at some point of course don't
hang your queen bishop g1 check is a threat now
but you said it white white should be better
it just doesn't feel very easy to prove
yeah now right back at you there's discoveries
here on this queen not quite bishop g1 but it'll
say okay yeah bishop c4 you open up the attack
interesting the trade happens i think white
just wins a pawn in the end i'm looking for some
kind of knight takes that for sacrifice probably
doesn't quite work out so i i don't
know if you can get away with it
but it's scary it's scary all right
and you can also take on e2 and take that
pawn in c3 to restore the material i guess
so but f7 falls in the end along with this
so does the knight well g3 is hanging first
ah duh okay yeah queen and knight double attack
over here good point full board awareness dan
um so that's actually a huge point i don't say if
probably takes h5 first there's no mating net on
the dark squares i don't think bishop can always
come back yeah so rook d3 now i i guess queen a1
hmm so my queen d3 is sort of forced i'm not
really seeing much more than that i don't
particularly want to offer a queen trade i would
like to keep my queen with the bishops dominating
but he plays rook d3 ah we're prop yep that'll
save us razor focus he wants that first victory
he does not want to botch this one look
at the position he's got the two big ships
a couple of bishops and well-placed want to
get this game if you're fed us say of you
know even if the computer says it's close to
equal from a practical point of view this is
much easier to be white and one of the big reasons
why is and icar did not play rook d8 which would
have encouraged in exchange of rooks is that the
white king has much easier access to the queen
side it was on king g2 and then just darted
whereas the king on g8 is cut off because the
bishops can operate on both sides of the board so
all right hikaru now oh he does he offers the rook
trade but but i'm with you this now here comes the
threat of bishop to b6 probably knight f6 is in
order but after the bishop moves or even to c6 you
kind of dominate the knight actually i love that
if knight f6 bishop c6 and you hold all the entry
points and good luck to your king you're on g yeah
the king's stuck right you see the kind of games
fiddle save is also very good at i was oh i did
he is really good at these but unfortunately
he's just in this shape today where he dropped
i jinxed him yeah you've been the
one commentator cursing him all day
wow icaru gets the pawn gets back defends
everything if bishop takes f4 was such a
sweet tactic i wouldn't even highlight it because
we're we're so you know just kind of blown away
blown away right now by nakamura's performance
but the point is if you took black was forking
the king and the bishop um this is still going to
be a draw but not a win for fedor savin what was
that move you might have just put your pawns on
dark squares cecaro doesn't think it's good either
he's trying to get after this h4 pawn
but ferris stage is going to put his
king over there and there's no way to
team up on it look at that smile by
hicar there yeah it was like a v for
vendetta face b for vendetta smile yeah
well i'm still smiling no matter what we've still
got 27 000 on twitch almost 9 000 on youtube it's
been an awesome day we already had one speech
championship match in the books magnus carlson
took down vladislav artemyev and a tale of of
two matches we thought both would be super close
magnus's match with artemyev ultimately was
this has been a showing by nakamura the likes
of which we've frankly never seen this is this
is as dominant as any scc match has ever been
um and that's that's that's the best we can say
about it so thanks for uh everyone being here
yeah they're just playing this one out there's
nothing that black can do with the opposite
colored bishops you cannot possibly kick the king
off the h3 square and you'll notice they're just
shuffling their pieces back and forth who's
going to offer the draw first they're not
going to do it now photos they have smiles
good to see a smile the day that's been tough
yep and hikaru will play h4 at some point i
feel like yeah he's gonna say it's gonna be
fun everyone buckle up everyone we're about
to see some fun stuff that'll save smiles
econo is gonna wait for 50 moves and play age four
if he does it if it's okay with you robert i'm
gonna get a snack and i'll be back in five okay
sounds good and he actually i think he was
scrolling through the game to see the movie
this is awesome although it's not exactly you know
torture he's by the way he just played h4 right
what he's doing is taking a little bit of
time off the clock uh the match clock and
at this point yeah i'm listening
what's your snack gonna be
you put down you're too high it's too high
right now yeah there we go more down more
down more there we go bring it close to the cam
for everybody yeah there it is there's happy icaru
oh if only the players could
see what you're doing right now
i'm gonna say if only your mom could see
what you're doing she would be frowning
oh so we're move 150 by the way
and look at the car he's just using the match
clock he's just going to accept the draw for but
letting the clock tick he looks good in that
sweater by the way again i've said it before
anytime i fed a save or hecaro both
actually both actually looking good in their
sweaters
this um a lot to talk about in this position
right danny what do you have for dinner tonight
great question i don't know um i brought some
salmon in for for uh lunch after this because
it left it we had we grilled salmon last night
you know donna makes her awesome it's garlic
ginger soy sauce a little sriracha oh my god the
best grilled salmon you know you've had it yeah um
and uh we always make a ton because i got to bring
some to work right so the kids know you don't eat
the last two pieces of salmon that's dad's okay
bring that into work waiting for me in the fridge
plus i eat salmon cold you never reheat
fish ever eat it straight up salmon oh
hey i mean that sounds delicious i grill the
salmon to perfection what you do is you take
the sauce you put on you make a tin foil bowl
you put the salmon with the skin down skin goes
down you put the salmon on and then you put the
extra ginger and garlic you rub it on the top
i grill it usually 350 degrees all you have to
do is set for 15 minutes and walk away it's done
okay you should have a cooking show i really
honestly i enjoy it so much i would just i
should just turn on the camera more and
just talk everyone through what i'm doing
uh everybody smiled at me for everybody's
sake i think you shouldn't do that you're
on camera enough danny how many hours
have you been on camera already today
been it's been a few a few um yeah by the
way what's going on here i don't say it was
better is black i was listening to your stories
aren't you surprised i paid attention to you
well i'm so i'm so glad um through the
batcave we go we shall analyze because
what happened in the opening here for us to get
here with fedo say of clearly better as black
king's indian ah the old school de5
with knight d5 don't see this every day
if you want robert i'm now out of my my
king's indian knowledge with this c6 b5 line
well what i was going to say is these lines are
not supposed to be that you know great for white
it's fine but doesn't give you your typical
advantage but it could be good in a one-off
blitz game when your opponent's not super
familiar because it's not played very often
but but federal staff was ready for it and
just to highlight kind of what robert's
talking about as far as the line this e5 idea
is a very typical approach in the kings indian
and the reason white doesn't just take twice just
so you know the common tactic is this pawn is not
really hanging due to immediate reversal tactics
and black wins the material with dark square
interest so to speak so if you're not familiar
with that king's indian tactic at least you
learned something today on the hikaru nakamura
radio network um but hikaru's idea of knight
d5 hits c7 but as robert said these are
not supposed to be great lines for white
that'll say of doing what he's supposed
to do right just equalizes very quickly
hd5 he's just winning a pawn right up right
this seems healthy to me yeah and i mean the
way this game is continued it's well the pawn just
actually was taken right and black is still better
because the healthier pawn structure you see that
there's one pawn island for black from the e file
to the h file and white has isolated b2 pawn well
that pawn might not even exist in the next couple
moves so yeah as you said the e file the h5 the
b2 palm will probably fall indeed it will now um
yeah i see chat how much time actually
went off the total game clock during that
opposite code bishop performance heard around
the world i wasn't i wasn't keeping track i
was wondering if you had any idea no no but if
you you can do some quick math i mean how many
moves they play 150 moves and then yeah carl
spent the remaining 40 seconds or so of his
clock right yeah quite a lot of time there
several extra minutes taken off the clock
so well what are the chances here
they're not as high as it might be with like
night versus night in some cases am i right about
that because often the knight is better with the
rook on one side of the board but they are they
are real right i mean you're up a healthy pawn
your rook is very well placed what what
are the winning chances here for black
compared to a normal like rook and knight
versus rook and knight with four on three
one of the main issues is that if the minor pieces
get traded the rook end game is theoretically a
draw not easy to accomplish even gary kasparov uh
has lost that theoretically dramatically jerome
pickett hashtag yeah yep i actually met him in
tons of steel at the beginning of the year and
i mean i talked to him briefly about it it was
cool to you know meet somebody who beat gary
it's so funny though because he has to know that
he was qui he's that game is quoted so often as an
example of even the best in the world are capable
of losing things like rook to b5 fedex is going
to get a dub for the first time today he just
laughed ikaro just laughed that was a blunder um
even the best in the world do what sorry i was
saying even the best in the world can lose drawn
positions and i apparently spoke it into existence
because zekaro one of the best in the world
is about to lose this otherwise drawn position and
uh but seriously if you don't pick it do you ask
him like hey man what's it like to be the most
quoted player because you beat gary kasparov in
a rook and four versus freaking three i'm sure it
actually bothers him uh you can speak to him about
that because he's played better games he just
happened to beat the biggest name in chess right
so right it's a weird thing whereas you know he he
won a game as obviously great he was up a pawn he
clearly played well but it was not his finest game
ever right it wasn't his magnum opus so uh must
right hey guys you know i was also a grandmaster
2700 plus pretty good at chess for many years
we end up focusing right on the individual that
you defeated rather than the game itself and
you know there is obviously some legitimacy to
that but at the end of the day people do make
mistakes we just saw hikaru drop a bishop
yeah um you know fenicev hopefully for
his sake and for his fan's sake he can
convert this one i think he should be able to
but danny what i'm looking at h1 square
dark color bishop so if the rooks can
get traded and you're left with some h pawns
and that's it that's why he carved played h5
yeah his car is focused got number 14
rocking finger in the focus right on the lips
he did anyway he knows this is not as easy as it
looks right because now he's got that corner pawn
okay it is winning but again there are
there are endings where even this particular
setup is not a win so you this is this
is really crazy to think about that
but just to highlight everyone a rook
trade is not possible because of the
wrong color corners so he caro is not totally
unreasonable for playing this out and wow um
isn't it funny danny how i'm sure that you
especially are tired robert why do you always
bring up the bishop and the you know promoting
no i i never get tired of it seriously i think
you don't have to lie to everybody while
we're alive sometimes you get tired of it
you like it i really do like it i like it
thank you i appreciate that this should
be five is still made to rook g5 omgs are
snaps if you take either way and steal me
you sell that so quickly hey there's one thing
i know it's how to lose a winning position
oh gosh so that um check and check
second check is the threat putting
the king on the first rank um
watch out the king is stalemated currently but
not anymore gt okay now now you're getting out
but after rook g8 do not play king h5 so that
was right an important little moment there if you
play you got to play h5 he does look at the clock
by the way federer down to just three seconds
but i think he's in the right place because
white's king is not in a good spot to blockade
the pawn so easily so with the rook all the
way on f8 so there's very good chances here
and there's no more stalemate tricks now this
is actually much better for federal save than
the earlier spot because you don't have that king
on that awkward square where there were all kinds
of stalemate tricks i think is going to get his
first win of the day right here i will finally
call it we see hikara smiling he agrees it's
time to throw in the towel the big fish earned it
the first big w and uh he will not go winless on
the dead but this is what is so impressive about
hit car is obviously he's winning all these games
that position you know a lot of these players
would just consider resigning at the start of
it he lost the bishop he blundered a full bishop
but he card made that as difficult as possible
and if you played that same ending over say
20 times i'm sure he would score a couple of
draws based on the time situation and everything
so really you know and the snake trick was
real right i mean federal staff was taking
his time for a reason he got under time pressure
because you know hikaru creates a lot of problems
for his opponents we say it a lot him and him and
magnus win more games than they're not supposed to
dr evil fingers precisely because of what you
just saw the skill right there and magnus we saw
you know hammer and i kept saying yet again are
telling me if outplays magnus to come up with a
loss right and that was what happened multiple
times in today's match and you know again it's
so we're you know we're giving credit where
credit's due there's a reason that that
that it's so hard to win against those guys um but
he does get his win by the way he's on the board
and knight h4 the open file favors black so
fedo saves king not exactly feeling the safest
over there on h2 not too many defenders and you're
removing one of the essential ones
by trying to trade off that knight
and also removing the knight makes d4 loose i was
going to say this position federal safe has to be
super careful close to equal right now but there
is a long distance relationship waiting to make
it the real thing like should we move to seattle
where you live or houston where i live yeah well
seattle has great things to do
outdoors yeah but it's cloudy all
right okay man you're so muddy though what i
said okay meg ryan and they're like all right
you know what we're gonna do instead of making
us choose we're gonna move to a new city we're
moving to cleveland f2 long distance relationships
that work you find a new city that's a pro tip
sorry i'm sorry i don't know where that came
from but yeah you know you went with it you
never stopped i didn't give up it's like i'm gonna
keep telling it to the last person in the room
is feeling awkward about it all right seriously
though this does you do have to be careful here
because white's positioned well defended right
now all of black's pieces are primed and ready
to hop over to the kingside this kind of
pawn chain is very indicative of a coming
kingside attack if you trade the queens
though then white's position gets good so
the attack whoa okay have you taken f2 h6 is oh
not knight f6 okay so there's all these ideas the
d7 was hanging that's why the rook didn't take on
f2 and knight f6 now becomes a threat because the
rook is no longer attack so let's say it trades
everything off but you made a good point if the
queens are traded now we like white in fact
trade and then f4 might even just be better
better for white in the end game because
white will quickly own the e-file um
i like it probably also considering f3 here okay
he goes for the trade i expect f4 to be played
f4 danny is one of those moves where
it's good with the rooks on the board
it may not be as great with the rooks off
the board because the black king will just
venture into the center and the d5 pawn
which is advanced and restricting some
of uh the territory that black controls but it
can become a weakness and is harder to defend
so look at hikaru gov fe-5 there could be a rook
f1 which just pins the bishop on the first rank
so federer is thinking about that wow oh
he goes for it this could be a turnaround
e6 okay this is this is the road for fedor
say of either getting his second win in a row
or or losing what maybe would
have been a two result position
c6 just can't move by akaru trying to remove the
defender of this past pawn and fetishive will have
time not right now because you would lose the d5
pawn with the tempo but he can protect d5 and like
b3 bishop b2 i guess that's his uh main point yeah
this is the key point to unwinding but now there's
ideas of takes takes and rook c8 yeah he goes
for it okay hold the phone you can't actually
take the bishop because e7 would then promote
the pawn so he has that one move to get it right
makes me wonder if there was an idea there
obviously the eval bar helps i wonder if
bishop e3 sack in the exchange was something
that white had um with these but no maybe not um
so actually how does hikaru deal with
this because if white gets bishop b2 in
yeah then there will be eventual rook g4
type of ideas in addition to that past e
pawn this spells trouble for hikaru speaking
of long-distance relationships that work right
yes indeed
i i not quite seeing a way out for a car he's
spending time he's very focused right now
and federal save i wasn't sure if he was
frozen but he's not i saw his eyes moving
he's also locked in just focused
so i think a car is trying to figure out
can he throw in a bishop g1 check is it
even worth looking at that bishop on c1 or
is white just getting bishop b2 in which case
i need to come up with a different type of
plan but bishop g1 check encourages the king
out to g3 or some kurdish forces out there
then you can throw in a bishop f2 check the
king is going on a bit of a journey for
white if you're trying to win the game
yeah this is a hard position you see
hikaru's focus there for a reason right and
moves like king f8 hardly work right you make the
trade and then white's coming to f4 and f7 this is
i mean understandable why hecarim makes a mistake
i i don't know how i would have played that
position as as black yeah and higher shakes his
head i think he was looking at some kind of rook
c2 doubling on the second rank but then e78 comes
too fast so this is just yeah this is well now
bishop takes d6 is a threat if it weren't check
because the bishop is finn by the way rook takes
c5 might actually be a threat take it right now
do it or take c5 and take d6 ask questions later
i think it works yeah these
these two pawns are too much
do it there you go i mean you thought
about it you got down to seven seconds
that might cost you you got to move
quickly now e7 and the point is after
rookie eight there's rook f4 and then rook
ffa check ah you head to f8 and it's over
so fed us about to take his second game in
a row unless something goes really wrong
in the next couple seconds yeah i don't think
icarl can stop it looking forward it's over wow
well i mean when we were highlighting artemia's
match versus magnus carlson we consistently talked
about the magical way to beat magnus is you've
got to win two games in a row you got to put him
in a position of psychological tilt um now
unfortunately for fedo say that has come after he
was down eleven to two eleven to one actually but
uh by the way this is a horrible system for black
uh if i don't say a blunder d5 is a bad move i
this reminds me of i used to play this system
and i got a win against gabriel schwartzman you
remember who gabriel sportsman is i know the name
american grand master um i caught him at the tail
end of his career let's say that right got a dub
against the g and uh it was in this exact line
d5 is a blunder let's go to the analysis board
just to show it it's actually a really funny
trick because even grand masters fall for it and
the staunton gamut with e4 uh there are multiple
moves g6 e6 knight c6 is actually the theoretical
best but d5 loses to this queen check because you
lose d5 and with it the e4 pawn falls black
is just down a pawn and white is doing well
although to fetishize credit despite playing a
subpar opening it's getting complicated right
the king on c1 isn't exactly the safest that
you've seen a king be but the king of g7 is no
better and bishop e6 offering exchange oh no you
couldn't take any six there because queen a3 check
oh wow let's show it six fails to check and lady
falls with the discovery what a nice little trick
the fedoce bounces back a little bit white
is still up a pawn and doing okay but
anyway to complete what we were saying dude
fettle say i've got two wins in a row that's
what you got to do when you're the underdog
make the favorite prove he can survive tilt
unfortunately for fedo save it came maybe too
little too late um but we'll see who knows you got
a third win i'll tell you what now you're cooking
and yeah i mean you talked about salmon so cooking
something that you enjoy i also enjoy cooking but
right now this position still has to be good for
car you are up a pawn and black's king is feeling
safer and safer and the reason why is you have
the queen on b3 staring on the diagonal you have
the rook on e1 that's challenged by the rook on
e8 but black has these two pieces the queen on
a5 and the knight on b6 ready to jump into the
game over here and actually photoshop gives up the
b7 pawn saying when i lose a pawn i open a file
so go for it have at that pawn i want the b
file to be opened to use it in hikaru's like
not gonna fool me with that but now
knight c3 forks the rook and the a2 pawn
wow rook d3 what a move there's no rookie one the
knight has no defense you have to back up to a4
and then you might see hikaru go for
this b7 pawn it might be chow time
like this even probably oh that
loses to rookie one and mate dan
hey don't check yourself on the back
rank dan was my nickname in high school
so i'm gonna not do that you also are
just the king of nicknames yeah yeah
although rookie one doesn't work anymore because
after the takes white still has queen to be
better saved trying his best but queen
b5 should do the trick i think for hikaru
trades the queens off by force there it is and now
you have a material advantage yeah that's a tough
one and a good rebounding victory for hikaru
i still don't agree with a lot of the opening
choices fido say has been playing given the match
situation chad said i'm hating on the dutch you're
darn right i'm hanging on the dutch yet again the
opening not the people um i'm i'm telling anish
oh lol you don't need to tell him we
know that anisha has nothing better
to do than watch these shows oh for sure
and just create tons of instagram posts
yeah is it their instagram tweet one thing he's
not going to be doing is working on his chess
wait he's actually playing at a tournament now
that i think about it is he yeah he had he scored
a a really nice win yesterday against wong hao it
shows how much you pay attention to your friend
i think i did see that but you know
by the way the uh the b-bond eval bar
likes white just a little bit those pawns
yeah b7 b8 seems that's going to do the trick
and there it is
oh look we have more italian
it's awesome when you get silent on me you know
i can just i can tell you're looking you're like
this again one more time for it's for the crowd
um this is not your normal
italian what happened here
this was a game between was this a magnus
hicaro game during one of their many matches
this year yeah i think they had a game either
in this exact position or very similar to this
go to the batcave again i got to see the opening
now you inspired the chess player in me again
way to go oh i care i'm sorry i'm sorry that
you care yeah i'm sorry i made you care brad
you always do that karen well this game's getting
pretty wild yeah we got an italian bishop e5 we've
seen this many times actually jokes aside this
was the lavonna ronian versus sorry the mbl versus
lavon aronian many times yesterday queen to b8
was played multiple times by lev against maxine
so this morning with d4 and then the d5 counter
shot to open e4 okay again yeah i jokes aside
just so you know this is kind of funny i'm going
to secretly surprise you i actually am trying to
start playing the italian instead of dutch so
i've been paying very close attention both to
yesterday and today i want i wanted to see the
opening difference hence the mental note i made
that the move bishop b6 was the difference in the
variation between this game and aronian's approach
you are an inspiration to the masses i hope
you know that i'm i'm trying to start playing
the italian it's what every top player plays and
everyone keeps making fun of my scotch yeah just
the fact that you are on the road to recovery is
really something that everybody's happy to hear
well you know what they say bless the broken
road as long as it leads to a good result and
i am hoping for that you just rascal flats
me i just rascal flats the bleep out of you
oh my gosh no one even likes pop country anyway
we have never been closer than that moment
because the broken road that led me straight to
you and well if you look at this position danny
that rook on b3 can head straight over to the king
side in a moment's notice with rook g3 there it is
and this could be a problem for hikaru as there
is an attack building it's been a good italian
for fedo save and by the way it's been a good
italian all day regardless of the scoreboard
he's had pretty good positions as white you've got
this isolated d pawn and then the four on three
white structure is much healthier and as robert
said there's uh potential for something over here
i'm guessing a4 gets played oh no he goes for
the pawn i didn't think he could do it he does it
he's a greedy greedy lad yeah he'll put the
queen on e2 and say you know what i grabbed
a pawn i'm gonna own it and the i think what you
were highlighting there is that it gives black the
active counter play yeah and white has his extra
pawn e5 but you can't really mobilize the pawns
just yet it's more about the potential attack and
pickard needs to find a couple moves here rook d4
is a good start stopping queen e4 where the bishop
and the queen would line up for a checkmate threat
and so now you can double the rooks in the
d file and try to take over uh the activity
yeah it's a great point and since we're on
the announcement still i'll just back up
again that was partly why i like day four and
i'm not sure it's any better than grabbing the
pawn but i like the idea of keeping the
tension because the deep one's not going
anywhere just felt like this bishop kind
of lacks a purpose if that's the case but
all right we're in the live position here better
save is well he's no longer up upon black stole a4
whoa oh a2 sorry that was unexpected but why
not there's no way to punish it look at that
oh look at that if you take with the bishop rook
b1 is coming but how do you continue this because
you can play bishop c2 here as even though it puts
the bishop on a hanging square the bishop on b3 is
pinned but he goes rook this is steps in the wrong
direction you can tell you don't really sacrifice
both your queenside pawns and then play rook to
e3 which doesn't actually have a concrete threat
well it has rookie iv as an awkward threat
right because if you trade you bring my queen to
her desired post i'm with you no i'm with you
federal state is going the wrong direction
and now the threat on d2 is leading to one
direction thank god harry styles left him
but um that's the second rank the second rank
is black for the taking and there goes cecaro
i almost want to play e7 here for white just like
push the pawn he goes for it he goes for it but it
was just a loss rook takes a five you get the
queen what in the world because i'm with you
he's like what i mean how many extra pawns does
black have three yeah this is this is bad news
i thought you were about to ask a
riddle how many extra pawns does
it take to you know to beat to beat a big fish um
seems like you want to answer that
question i i don't know the answer but
queen c2 seems to be a start because
it's a double attack of f2 and b1
um oh by the way if queen of queen
of two there was bishop d5 to follow
how's that sapping now i was teaching one not
just crushing it is bishop d5 to follow like owie
in the words of the illustrious dr evil ouch
bibbles i don't know if you were watching earlier
it just came out of me i you know everyone
has a little fat bastard inside him and i said
you can keep you i'll get there wait i i just
it wasn't dr evil it was gold member wasn't it
oh yeah goldfinger goldfish ouch can
bibbles yeah yeah does he also say it
no oh i love this system i love b5 officially
rooting for fedocia because of the opening hold it
it's dubious for black i think you're rooting
for people what kind of unbiased commentator
are you i just if they play an
opening i love i want a result
okay there you go it's a bononi with gusto
you're like i'm not sitting around i'll play a6
sort the structure d6 i've i didn't ask to play
b5 in this position you know what i did i saw
the opening and i took it okay took it yes i don't
want you're like that's what this opening's about
of course of course the major issue now is
look at the c4 square that is permanently
whites for the taking cannot kick that pony out
from there black's bishop on f8 is extremely
strong and i don't mean that seriously it's
staring it to its own pawns this is no good
i love how you go right to just telling me how
why this opening is so bad um you know when you
hit me with a varsity blues reference what do you
want that's right well i'm gonna go right back at
you i'm gonna play g6 move the knight punch f5 and
this looks pretty now we'll see if you can use it
um the real threat is actually
to bring the knight to c6
i guess that's your new nickname do
they call you mox in high school too
not quite back in high school i could throw
pigskin that's i'm more more compared to uncle
rico than anyone else in my life g6 and f5 is
coming it is the system i like though seriously
wait what's this though hey this looks
really bad nakamura's put on a clinic i've
had to bust my opening this is not looking
good no it's not eight by five i just lost
completely lost for me money for you remember
you're not playing you're commentating yeah
sometimes you forget i do from time to time um but
seriously we are having a great time it's a ten
game lead for nakamura i'm gonna guess it gets to
be even a little bit more before we move to bullet
officially this is the last game though uh shout
out to everyone who wants to subscribe with your
prime throw us your prime because it's time for
the primetime smackdown coming up see what happens
in the next games between me and donya naradiski
um and more prime time matches uh coming up
in our next scc shows and other big events um yeah
man this is this is wild i mean we're having a
good time and we're lucky to get to do what we do
even if it's a lopsided match but i'm i'm just so
impressed by icaro today and i won't play this
opening anymore if that's what you want to hear
that does make me happy to hear
that you're improving your openings
but also hikaru just even these little moments
uh a couple moves ago he didn't recapture and
most chess players would they get away with the
analysis board because what were you just saying
about the recapture right i missed that on move
uh after 16 b takes c3 by ferocious yeah people
are reactionary after b takes c3 most people just
take back and don't think twice but the car went
b3 because he said my knight on c4 is a bit loose
and i want to move my knight from a5 into c6
i'll win the c3 pawn later more important
is just improving my knight's locations
and then the knights go to town
seriously what an instructive idea
b3 you guard the knight eyeing that the square and
the tempo is more important than the pawn on c3
and ikaru starts winning material because of
it last move queen to d5 is going to force an
engine with a couple of pass pawns i would want
nothing to do with if i was fedo save um wow
i don't know what to say now what do we do did you
talk to each other yeah i know but it was awkward
ugh
all right there are three past pawns on the
bar dude there's that's a lot yeah too many of
them i i didn't like the silence but i didn't
want to be the first one to speak so oh man
speed chess championship delivering again in
many different ways today again this is the
second of our double header if you missed
magnus carlson versus vladislav artemyev
lucky for you it will be available uh on youtube
and on twitch um forget if our videos on twitch
are only for subscribers i don't know but
either way it's available on twitch and youtube
and you can check it out and hear hikaru nakamura
and our second match of the day is putting on
a show he is indeed um look
at these this pawn chain
too many pawns better say
hoping that something can work out for
him but there's nothing here is there
someone goes i'm still laughing
at the varsity blues reference
at least i made the appropriate reference for
that movie and not the one that's normally made
yes i mean you know exactly what i'm talking about
i could pretend that i don't just so you'll do it
but i am going to acknowledge that yes i do know
oh man oh man g4 everyone james
van der beek was a thing yeah
you were definitely a dawson's creek guy
gotta be kidding me dude if i was i would
have been on purse team percy not team
dawson for the record wait he just gave
his rook on c3 wait and he'd take it because
the d-pawn that was nice it doesn't matter
if you take c5 everyone hikari was gonna sack and
play d7 it's dirty it's wrong but it's happening
oh man remember that joshua jackson's
name and that show was perfect
that's going way back even for me i'm gonna
i'm gonna brag to my wife about that later
because let's be honest she was probably
into percy and dawson on seventh
evan 7th heaven right before on the wb right
before 7th heaven you have dawson's creek
i'll tell you what we are going to have
an awesome last 30 minute segment don't
go anywhere everyone it's time for the prime
time smackdown and hess and i will be right back
don you look over there there's a thing that
just happened mess with your mic for a little bit
there is a thing that just happened why isn't his
time running crap my time i no it was i was hate
thinking about that we don't just start the time
of the moves when i want to beat somebody and i
appreciate that we do it but it's a good thing i
was connecting my good mouse because that's what's
needed to beat you i can't just use any old mouse
i've got to use the danny wrench killer mouse
really yeah that feels so good when you say
it like that no i you gotta have specialized
equipment to beat danny lynch you also got
to get a good night on that before i feel
this is like the worst white side of a caro con
in the history of white sides of the caro khan
you do have some pretty good well it's all pawns
and no talk but sometimes that's a good thing all
pawns and no talk no all pawns are no hope it's
the correct queen's game no hope oh no hope okay
yeah all pulled still hope it wasn't oh i totally
believe you look at that that was a wonder look
at that all right emergency measures okay that
little piece you just gave me how about that
yeah if only you didn't have that knight
on uh night on e5 i would be in good shape
oh man no i thought i won more
look at your horrible bishop yeah i honestly can't
move here wow by the way can you appreciate that
i just i just dominated your face facial
face facial are we gonna make this about
faces because i can definitely make it about
you just got crushed bro you might as well
have taken the l in that game as my 15
year old say he would say take the l dad
take the l you know what i see is 0.5 uh and and
that as far as i remember indicates a drawn game
and that was a money decision which you
just did there that was that was awesome
i think i'll do more of that taking
the draws and positions up with these
positions that are completely winning for you um
i don't know why i did how about that that was a
great move too maybe i should repeat moves now
take a page out of danny wrench's face uh book
i know that i do feel the pain i'm going to do
the unethical thing and text my wife back and
let myself lose on time i just have to sit there
for 30 seconds instead of doing anything else
girl i'd love to sit there for
30 seconds and admire my position
i mean this is amazing back to my wife yes
ma'am i will do what you asked me to do
i resigned you can go answer that doorbell
that just rained no i've resigned i'm not
playing anymore you can walk resign
you can walk away i'm telling you
all right i have one more chance i'm so
upset that i let you off at that draw
the comeback of the century begins now
and we are back here in a match that has uh
has been full of statements by the defending
champion and the number one overall
seed ikar nakamura leads 11 to three
and uh hess and i were talking off air there's
just it's just uh it's been dominant it's been
crazy it's been you know you're disappointed for
federosay of a guy that's had an incredible year
by the way right and and so so consistent in the
speeches grand prix um and and many other events
but wow hikaru nakamura has shown up today and
shown up big time as he looks to fill out the
bracket in front of us right now robert yeah
i mean it's clear at this point he is going to
move on to face wesley so in the semi-finals and
danny before this whole event started if you said
that hikaru nakamura wesley so magus carlson
maxine rashtray lagrave were in the final four
i think that probably would have been the picks
of most people and there was fantasy so i'm sure
people did fill the brackets with these four i'm
guessing it's the most common uh we sure know what
these gears did anish anish geary took vladislav
artimus to beat him by four points beat himself do
you know that yeah i know yeah it's hilarious he
was objective wasn't he but then he was objective
was there collusion in he's like he
can't beat artemia are you kidding me
he's just like you he speaks about himself
from the third person right do you think he'd
also watch seventh heaven does he know the
candid family yeah that's probably where he
got his good american pop culture knowledge
as a kid right spent a little too much time
watching the old wb on dutch radio network he
had to hit the box a few times to get it to relay
all right well we have it kara nakamura
with an 11 game lead uh sporting his lucky
hoodie against vladimir fedorosev who will be
burning that hoodie the moment the match is over
let's do it it's bullet time i do like
the hoodie though for both of them
but uh right now hikaru his rating 34 15 and
bullet fetishes at a lowly obviously joking
30-78 oh we get this line ooh they should eat two
no this is okay nutty i like it for white though
he knows the theory yeah he doesn't seem to mind
one bit here yep white's pawn structure is stable
but the bishop on b6 doesn't look that great right
now but watch for the knight from to move from c6
black to push the pawn on the c file and free up
that bishop to a better diagonal in the future yep
and sometimes i was gonna say even bishop
a5 is a subtle awkward move to watch out for
um ecardo has brought all the pieces to the
king's side gonna try to use the c4 square
that's true right he can place c6 first and brings
bishop back there's there was a threat of knight
d7 so the car regarded that now he'll play c6
and relocate if you trade the c4 square opens up
right so g4 now hits the queen where's
that queen going the c8 i guess
a sad retreat is rook f2 wow tough you know what i
don't like what you highlighted before i could say
it we're in the same same wavelength it literally
gave me indigestion talking about the bishop
you know not to you know promote
anything but a pepto bismol might do this
yeah pepto-bismol um not a sponsor of the show
no certainly not besides i prefer tomes okay
um rook to e2 played again this bishop is bad
this knight is good um small b6 prevents bishop c5
it's painful look at the dynamics though the pawns
four on two from the e3 h file and then the same
in black's favor from the a to the d file so
interesting to note that the king on g8 in is
less safe than the king on h2 watch out for
some future ideas with f5 and here it comes
yeah he's preparing it in fact yeah this is turned
around i was loving the the knights dominance of
the bishop earlier but not anymore that'll save
if he can punch f5 this is a different game
for sure and he's actually playing really quickly
he's up seven seconds counting down now but he
built up a lead in the clock
and that's rare against nakamura
he wants to d3
love to just play g4 there are
trick on e5 no there's none
okay bishop h4 and i can't get g4
because f4 is hanging right now
so rook f2 first but if this move comes in and you
can slide the bishop back to g3 suddenly f5 is a
real threat here he goes he's going to slide the
bishop back and try to manufacture this idea this
looks very good f5 push him oh yeah but arnold's
breaking through first who's better here and why i
no idea i would maybe bring the queen all the way
back oh b3 even nicer because it pinned the knight
so rook takes c5 he does it oh he
wins the pawn but the d-pawn's rushing
knight if one check that's the big deal oh
you couldn't play rook d2 because of the fork
oh so you oh so you wow if you take
just a queen happens a queen appears and
blocks a head i don't understand why it's only
plus two for black like what because the knight
trap wait rook takes f1 and they work no yeah you
have rookie eight there's no check by the queen
yeah but oh he promotes first i think they just
played like the most accurate way to play the
position too that was bananas that they figured
that out and if black can't win this because if
you take b3 you lose a5 oh he just tricked him
the pin bishop d2 was a mine a land mine square
let's show it on the analysis board real quick
that's a landmine tactic the bishop was ideally
placed but he puts it on a square that is pinned
to the king and acaro doesn't have to be asked
twice if you take it was a draw but he plays
a4 and you can't take because rook b2 would win
the piece and so white is just dead lost to the
coming a takes b3 wow what a move what a finish
icaru is now up 12 games i'm just he is really
playing some phenomenal chess today and in this
current game this position i've had from the
white side many times you want to dislodge the
queen from d5 and then push d5 yourself to open
up that bishop on b2 that's your uh kind of the
pride and joy of the future of the position
here bishop c1 he said re-routes it because
there were threats of bishop to h3 so maybe
he wasn't quite able to get that plan in order
to page five play chases the queen
here goes bishop e3 to defend d4
no bishop b2 because he still has aspirations
of d5 and the knight protected the bishop
but as was the case before d5 is not bishop
h3 that's why he put his king in the corner
but now bishop e6 stops d5 before it can happen
this is important it's an isolated pawn you want
to blockade these isolated queen pawns and that
is exactly what fedocer is doing he should be
slightly better in this position the car looking
a little frustrated with his position there
but we'll d oh f4 that's a move yeah committal
yeah might have been a little impatient too
i was wondering if he had kind of fixed his
problems if he just backed up the bishop but
now he's got double attacks on d5 and f7
wow look at fedo speaking of committal
as you would say honey badger don't care yeah the
adventure takes what he wants that's exactly what
he's doing oh you can't take on g4 with
the bishop because queen of seven mate
and if you take with the queen there's
queen f6 you take with the queen
queen f6 if you take with the bishop queen of
seven's mate i know the computer says equal but
i have no idea what to play here is black what a
freaking move here comes queen of six oh always
in the bishop c5 check coming is that the
idea that was set if king ji won bishop c5
and if the king runs out here comes now black
is winning oh my gosh we take [ __ ] holy bleep
that'll save the monster he's gonna go rook takes
b2 next oh my god rook g2 oh he just takes the
bishop g5 and he's of g5 okay so hikaru has been
brilliant all matched this was to my eyes the best
game yeah this was this was maybe the game of the
match in bullet um queen takes g2 out of nowhere
and as long as he finishes it off i guess look at
hicaro doing what he does best making it
an absolute mess despite being dead lost
yeah he's he's and it's completely busted
hard to call it the game of the match if he
doesn't win but as long as said it finishes
that that bishop that queen g2 was just
nasty wait wasn't it oh bishop was pinned
i was like what's there yeah yeah yeah
is coming now though uh oh he oh no
he's only got three seconds though and
we know how tricky the queen is in these
cases one second yeah oh no he lost spawn
maybe
he wants to make a net bishop f7 is a
threat bishop f7 would be a threat but
that's why i put his queen on e4 there oh
he's got richie five now yes he stops it
what is happening i don't see how black can win
this take on a five no can you do it he does it
yeah he does it and he's gonna bring his king oh
then he's gonna get rid of the v4 pawn wow wow
that was the game and then it wasn't
i still think it's the game of the match what
does it cardo do that seriously that was just like
retake g2 was just sick like most people just
think about resigning oh i'm getting checkmated
fedozer says not so fast i am going to sack my
queen out of nowhere that was so incredible and
then hikaru holds that position absolutely
no business doing so getting mated probably
at some point with the rook and bishops
wow crazy crazy stuff what a great game
and like we said the one minute segment
would not disappoint regardless of how you
feel about the scoreboard um i don't know
what's going on here but uh better say of
king side's falling apart yeah it is it's
he's playing these lines that i have played
plenty of times myself not very good for white
so i continue to play it knowing full well it's
not good look at your e3 square your h4 pawn yeah
black is perfectly safe to sound the center and
wait knight takes queen d6 is coming dark
squares are coming winter is here between d6 yeah
sorry that came out of nowhere what because
the queen g through his mate if you move the
knight i know and i was shaking my head because i
didn't know what else to do sometimes my emotions
my therapist told me it's okay to haven and
just like rub yourself when you're overwhelmed
they present damn yeah it's okay to do those
things when you're not in the middle of a
broadcast okay when i'm not in the middle of
the match i'll remember that i knew queen v6
was coming there was no way to stop it i'm still
thinking about that marvelous queen takes g2 check
let me take g2 that that's that was so nasty
and i just i want to know where the force wind
was in my head for my own sanity but um wow
but as as this as the show has been
all day it didn't matter because i
found a way to get the draw in that game
yeah it's just really incredible that even in
games that were like okay fedo say has done it
you know he got the lead here in that individual
game and then nope hikaru is fighting back
taking a pawn here giving a check there
creating problems for fetose that he just
can't fully solve so it's unbelievable stuff
now we are what in a position that neither
side is happy to play i'll say that
what's going on with this pawn
chain you would love to play rook
a1 to g1 that's your best move jump that rook
over everything yep but good luck doing that
and actually for black if you can you're going
to take this bishop on c1 if you can somehow get
your bishop to h6 yeah and that bishop e3 e3 is
calling my name and fedo say if here's the cry
okay timothy chalamet
i like to uh when i cry queen oh my gosh
oh i almost called you the gordon ramsay what
i meant to call you the uh mason uh ramsay
oh look at b5 though speaking of calling my name
light squares are also on the agenda for recaro so
queen h5 threatens queen of three
don't want to allow that check you pick
up the rook next oh wait uh queen b5
might not have been with the doctor order because
now you can't really stop queen f3 it's a quick
queen of three is going to be between three
rook up two is mate so he has to run the king
so this d3 pawn is hanging and the queen
on b1 was defending that so that's probably
an important difference here yeah
probably all you should do is just take the pawn
i think he's gonna try to get the
bishop in but i don't see what it does
right it feels a little bit slow either
settle on a perpetual or grab the d-pad
red pill or blue pill you choose
oh look he took the red pill
and i'm wondering if it's important that the
queen protects the rook on g8 probably not but
the king won't there's not a perpetual check
for white to work yeah i think it is important
even if you end up walking over and allowing
a rook check on the g file for a trade
oh but queen e7 yeah there's
another jbs bishop g5 too wait
okay queen takes oh that pawn was important
who's doing what here this is too confusing
quiche five line those queen and bishop
up for a queen e3 check here comes
but hikar must have some kind of repetition
available to him yeah you would think that the
queen can hold on the light squares the
geometry of the board says so wait what
oh wow hey carlo lost on time i've never seen that
happen before i've never seen that happen before
seriously i i i look like well
that doesn't happen very often
oh my gosh increment yeah that was surprising he
almost took too much time with queen of seven and
knight knight h5 he was trying to figure out a win
instead of just settling on the draw which i guess
when you're up you know 13 games you can afford
to do that um but yeah he just lost track of time
happens to all of us and what's going on here
white is has that sort of king's indian structure
where you press uh forward on the queen side but
are you there in time that's an important question
yeah because uh h4 is coming yeah you're not gonna
like it yeah the h file a wee bit of a problem
uh oh in comes the queen
pg four first which four looks
good but you should take the four
quinn because h3 queen h2 check and then
if queen e4 this queen issue and then
queen each one trading the queen's off and
winning the rook on a1 at the end oh wow
we need four you check twice everyone the trade
has to happen and a skewer is your uncle on a1
i think it's over because there's a double attack
here yeah it's not just g3 it's it's this idea so
as long as cecaro sees that game i get you know
he'll do he'll play king e2 and give up the rook
and try for something on the game is there
maybe but carl was considering taking here
because of that exact idea i mean i think was
the best he goes for it wait what look at that
he goes king e2 i didn't know it was
gonna be a draw but that's the idea
what is it all right oh queen e6 now going 27
mate or queen 26th threatens 27 mate and queen f7
oh my gosh allison oh my god the email bar is
going nuts he gave c6 and he's holding oh 25.
devastating devastating how many times
are you gonna repeat what i have to say
honestly i thought that you just couldn't
hear me earlier i just thought that you would
you're such a child that's the next thing you say
oh man that was nuts right there seriously hey
karu goes queen h1 and king e2 and somehow white
was holding there but he went to the wrong
square on d3 which allowed the whole queen b5
check if he had stayed on d1 all black has dude is
a perpetual because of the mate that's crazy right
let's i'll show it on the analysis board real
quick real quicky the losing move was king to d3
if you stay here the point everyone is you
have to take a draw because if rook d8 then
queen f7 is made there's no way to guard queen
d7 mate coming so the losing move was king to d3
oh my gosh it's not fair it's not fair
it's not fair hello well you're going to try to
go it's so funny if they could see your face off
camera you said it's not fair and then you gave
this smile like danny and i both know i'm not
going to be able to do this i don't want to do
it yes you're absolutely right you couldn't be
as immature as me if you tried no i i couldn't
you're a hundred percent so i i don't try also
this is one of the weirder rook lifts ever like
there's a bishop still what happened here just
brooke wanted to get in the game yeah
oh this looks bad white's up a pawn
the f file is he cars for the taking rook d to
f is meant by knight h7 with a fork that would
be sick that's a fork a4 full board awareness
thank you very much now rook takes a seven oh i
thought he would just take right away yeah i think
carl should have taken right away shook his head
he's just playing too well right now
but we still have about 8 000 on youtube 25k
on twitch don't go anywhere interviews with
the players after the games are finished we'll
talk about the semi-finals robin and i preview
what we think will be two epic match-ups between
magnus and mbl icaru nakamura and wesley so um
don't look now d7 hanging blunted
it aw snap it happened again
again wisconsin um that was perfectly timed
it literally happened right in front of me
uh if someone doesn't clip that you have
no soul five of you should clip that
oh god seriously and look hours look at the nice
finish of the game too we think it's oh my god
rook a7 sick yeah have they even started
the next game yet um yeah they have oh my
you are just adorable um you know i'm just trying
to uh give a little shout out to jennifer coolidge
she deserves it yeah the unnecessary shout out
to jennifer coolidge that every chess show needs
every chess show gets a shout out to sheboygan
i mean how many people know about sheboygan
i would go this way every single time is one of
the most underrated okay craft beer rear beer
capitals of the world thank you very much it
sounds like you've had a few because you can't
even say the word it's been eight hours under
these lights and you know how it is to do the
sec this isn't over the board candidates you
know where you get to take seven breaks yeah
you're talking about the lights now
you really are going full varsity
it's been a long day it's been a lot of
fun too yeah yeah not a lot of fun for
fedo save right now you know what why don't you
just finish this one without me buddy turn the
lights off well i can commentate this and we see
your screen it's lit in a very dark room and danny
what are you doing over there wait no i don't
want to see you again on the camera you want to
see the full screen i can show you what i'm doing
over here i got my chat over here this is where i
got twitch youtube i got slack and our run of show
doc the road of show doc we're very professional i
scroll through my google sheet we mark off items
with strike through text who doesn't love strike
through text makes you feel like you did something
right right through the text we get down to our
we're now down here right we're in the uh the
last portion of the show that's our run of show
what and it's in comics it's in comic sans if
you don't use comic sans what are you reading
okay scc quarterfinals the show anyway then i got
the big uh the big monitor over here on the other
side where i'm doing the chess well hello darkness
my old friend it's good to see you back here danny
here we go hikaru here we go i've
totally lost sight of the chest
because of everything that's just
been happening here you've succeeded
it's ruined me but hey caro
succeeded i mean this is just
you know there's really little that can be said
at this point obviously we can talk about the
specifics of the individual chess games
but 19 and a half to four and a half yep
not what i thought was gonna happen you know how
much i'm on tilt that i'm literally singing sean
mendes in my head have mercy on me take it easy
on my heart even though you don't have to get 20.
carl nakamura i'm falling apart have
mercy mercy and then you punch shawn
mendes in the face and say you're the most
irritating male pop singer since gavin degraw
whoa what do you got against gavin
degraw always i don't like that
either but where did that come from like you
don't like sean minnes you talk about this
every single time you did a pretty yeah you're
pretty nice too in there i'll give you that
uh but i had another thought now what oh we're
smarter chess oh no don't worry about him
we locked him in the basement he's pumping
out semi-finals predictions as we speak
um all right but seriously we're gonna have great
interviews this has been an awesomely fun day
chess is the most entertaining thing
on twitch everyone knows it by the way
if you happen to be watching chess for
the first time hit that follow button
um we cover everything here the biggest events in
the world not always this much of a lopsided pop
culture hysterical show um anyway does
d4 move yeah look at that fetose whoa
there's seven minutes remaining in
this match oh my god i gotta focus
okay so fetish takes the e5 pawn but he is even
in terms of material but that king of g8 that rook
on h8 is entombed over there it's stuck wants to
get out desperately and you need to play king h7
but that walks into an even bigger attack so not
easy for fedor save to coordinate all his pieces
not easy at all slave to chess on chess tv
said candles would be nice for our studio
in the dark lit room we should get some
scented candles it does i do get a little
sweaty in here under the light so scented
candles might add to the ambiance we'll do
that thank you slave to chess i'm not giving
you a premium membership because you trolled
yesterday's show pretty bad so if you were
a better basic member i would reward you
need a username i love you oh my gosh um anyway
this looks very bad for fedocera because all of
a sudden the attack is is on the g7 square you
should probably play h5 for black to keep the g
file closed but that doesn't look very
enticing because now look at g6 it's not over
and your king stuck then the rook
is stuck as well and e6 is weak
f4 but the knight on d5 is so
you like black's position if
it wasn't for the fact that the
king and rook aren't playing um
now e6 will be traded for g6 that's fedor saves
hope here everybody one last chance at a dub is
what he's thinking but he might just lose a piece
instead with rookie one and bishop c5 a wee bit of
a problem yeah yeah so is your accent but other
than that everything's perfect in the world yeah
and the pandemic that's a problem well i did sing
shawn mendes for the first time on a chess tv show
it wasn't enough to deter hikaru from getting 20
points despite the begging for mercy um and uh
there you go yeah it's uh it's a tough day for
photosafe seriously you know i mean we've had a
we've had a lot of fun and there have been some
really impressive and instructive moments but
overall like just not what we saw coming right and
it's not like shade dejkar or fedo say it but just
like this has been a dominant semi-par semi-final
performance and hikaru making a statement
yep and he really is just he's unstoppable look
at that he doesn't take the h3 knight after
bishop was captured he takes on g3 first opening
the position up sacrificing a piece because bishop
g2 was possible there if white wanted to keep
the material it's funny because it's probably
not a sound sacrifice and we see that if white
just plays bishop g2 here which photosafe does
he has queen f3 next but you know there's
95 ideas you can just keep chomping on pawns
if you want them for karu it's not like
white's king will ever find total shelter
so how ooh e5 that's a move i like
it i would say how can black castle
queen said quickly and the answer is you can't
this is nuts it almost looks like
fedo say have played the bond cloud
something you expect the person leading the
match to do with the king on f2 what is going on
uh oh well here it comes once
there was the king castles this is
very good news here comes knight takes d4 and the
g don't check all right don't forget bishop g4
check good call dan don't forget bishop g4 pinning
all damn are you calling me dan i don't know
i c3 you're gonna play rookie one he did
get out of the pressure there so i thought
hikaru's attack was gonna roll but somehow
he keeps it tricky and watch out for knight
things be seven and then creepy five check was
coming oh god double check him queen c8 mate
that's a problem dude it's nasty because the
bishop guards d6 so knight d6 check and queen
c8 was mate and he just takes the knight and
gets away with it because okay now there's a
mate coming on b7 does takara turn this one
around two i might just walk right out wait
rook f3 check king e2 the bishop covers all the
squares we've broke no we're getting should i
take him broke up to a key yeah who takes work
of two kingdoms he's safe i think hikaru isn't
oh it's just winning the bishop
now which hits the rook on h8
uh uh-oh i saw that bar i have no idea but it's
it's he just takes c5 i think he had rookie 3 and
queen h4 maybe that was the idea anyway either
way doesn't matter although oh he gets the four
forces the fork man oh he denies
the fork go fork yourself he says
that was really nice oh my gosh a couple of
denied forking opportunities not something
that happens every day oh man 92 check he could
have won the rook oh he missed it another fork
okay but oh my goodness is
still gonna take this one
yeah he just won a rook wow he does strike
and it may be his last chance because only
one game remains here hikara goes back to the
old number one they say the old terminator right
we know that vaughn had the fastball give me
vaughan right carlos got old number one with b3
okay but danny just one thing that you're
missing this whole equation looking at cars
rating right now oh he's a below 2400 he's
rouge is sitting there like just laughing
right his own 17 year old self like they're all
happy that he's now the highest rated yep the
andrew tangs the daniel ditzkies the farouzas
they're pretty happy that he lost 10 points
and well now we have uh is this
the last game it is the last game
yeah i mean unless we see a blunder and a
nightmare in the next few seconds we will have
about 25 000 of you sticking with us i know you're
all not going anywhere we got interviews coming up
and we still got about 8 000 of you on youtube
so this has been a great day and a very long day
double scc i couldn't have had it any other way
to reign in the speed the speedchest semifinals
which start next weekend yeah those are going to
be amazing obviously four very deserving players
and for the pleasure eliminate today artemia
put up a great fight against magnus carlsen
and for fedo say he wishes he could take this
back but he's just probably happy that he was
playing in this in the first place he's always
just so appreciative of the opportunities that
he has every time we interview him so i am
looking forward to hearing his thoughts and
what went wrong and if he could restart the
match maybe what he would do differently
right yeah he did beat farouja and what was
a bracket buster for a lot of people right it
took overtime but ali alireza faruja has lost in
the first round now both this year and last year
in 2019 to lavonne aronian so we know ferruja
has a great future um but uh that'll say have
sent him home this year well queen takes e1
was winning with rook c1 was it i know roxy
won actually immediately with queenie three check
where's that oh nice it was sick and he missed it
is he going to get the dub anyway no it's
falling apart hey carl's bringing rook d8
although rook takes e7 yeah there is tactics
everywhere oh now rook takes us check oh
so it's over also the rook and he wants protected
so it's rook takes to it a secondary problem he's
forcing the issue um as long as you don't
play king f1 and allow bishop check yep
and caro sees it he tucks the king safely to
bed on the dark squares and he's gonna take
the last game of this sec here winning a piece and
should be the game these pawns are are not enough
i don't even think you can keep the pieces
bishop b5 is my bishop d7 oh she's getting
a queen i i was just like yeah just get the
queen but and make him get up at bishop d7
is even better yeah that's a problem right
he goes bob barker what's the whole thing
i'm thinking of happy gilmore bob barker
totally different story no that's exactly
what it is i know i'm just trying to make
you feel like i'm what he's won johnny
you only make a happy gilmore reference
probably one and a half times the broadcast
you like no that's not true no you don't oh
oh look at that move king c5 torturing look
at the way white's gonna win everyone is
with oh i thought he was gonna go with irregular
opposition but maybe he thinks he can get back in
time because he's holding the f5 pawn right and
the f5 square covers b1 so he takes on f5 will
put his bishop on b1 play pawn to f1 oh my gosh
yeah the technique is accurate it's super precise
as they say and hikaru takes this match by a
final score of 22 and a half to five and a half
boy have we had a day if you are one of a lot
of people still here who's been here all day
seriously thank you so much it's been it's been a
lot of fun robert and i will be right back enjoy
the final segment of our prime time smackdown
to our subscribers we appreciate your support
stay around for interviews and we will
be having those in just a few minutes
the comeback of the century begins now
although i will point out you beat almost
everybody else 3-0 and included didn't you
beat hammer threo i believe so you know who
you've never beaten 3-0 in a smackdown wrench
whatever makes you feel good about yourself man
i mean that was incredibly impressive every time
you talk i feel less than stop talking down to me
talking to okay no more talking down that just
like that right there that was what you just did
was exactly that i'm i'm getting under your
skin that's that that's part of that's what
i learned from the greats gary kasparov and
you know and company very important to employ
you know psychological pressure on the opponent
let's make him get under your scheming movements
that's exactly what i'm doing has anyone ever
told you that your kasparov is so freaking good
like that is one of the best gary kasparov
impersonations i've ever heard in my life
i hate you for that move i appreciate when
i'm when i play the real i am not not one of
those danny wrench kind of items but levy i'm
sure we'll uh we'll exchange some impressions
oh you see as soon as i as soon
as i burn you there's a blunder
i feel so bad about myself right now i
feel bad i actually feel bad i'm being mean
i need to stop being mean
whoa oh look at those moves
those primos are scary i know i can't
move as fast i feel like i'm like a like
steward for manchester look what i can
do hey look what i can do almost down me
all right back to the old drawing board for dan
indeed
and we are now joined by our players
of the second scc match of the day
icaru and vladimir thank you so much for joining
us um vladimir starting starting with your side we
know obviously today did not go the way you
the way you mapped out and and robert and i
didn't have a lot of questions besides asking
you what would you have done differently second
time around obviously hikaru had his a game
today but in hindsight now with a match that
got away from you pretty early what would you
have done differently in terms of your approach
actually so much start with a huge disconnection
from my side and then i got tilting so
i do i don't think that's in the world we can
name second player who is such a good as hikaru
in the situation when your
opponent tilted and that's
that's why this is much ended how
much how it's ended and also he
he was so perfect concentrated till the end of
the match i found many great practical ideas but
uh he always was better physically mentally and
again in the game now played me uh in intense game
i mean hikaru from where we were sitting i was
saying that you were really playing some of
the best chess i've seen from you in this kind
of speedchest championship match format and as
early as game two you went really active and kind
of pounced on vladimir in that position did you
have any specific preparation because you have
acknowledged how strong vladimir is and what a
tough opponent he can be for you yeah so i mean
first of all what i would say is that um not not
to like sort of discredit my previous opponents
but for all the previous matches i i didn't
actually do any preparation whatsoever um whereas
for this match i did quite a bit of preparation
and um and so so credit to vladimir because he
is a very strong player and he did beat ali reza
in the first round um yeah i think i think to
match there were a couple things first of all um i
i thought i played very very well i think
it was maybe the third game when i had maybe
10 seconds and he had the minute or something
like this i thought the third game i played
very very well when i had no time um and so i
played very well when i had little time on the
clock and i thought that was probably the
main thing i did well in the five plus one
um but mainly it just things just seemed
to be working the preparation worked out
i got a lot of good positions um and i mean
it was very strange because it felt like uh it
got away from vladimir probably in the five plus
one um but but yeah that's how it goes sometimes
vladimir you you um to go to some extras who knows
you you played the italian consistently and you
seem to be getting some pretty decent positions
as white uh regardless of of the final result
was that part of your prep and um would you would
you stick with an opening like that consistently
uh given the the good positions you were
getting out of the opening in blitz against
prep for icarus much but my prep doesn't work
really well and he he also played the position
that i prepared better than myself today and uh
he just outplayed me tactically i i guess it was
the main things why i lost so many permission
position his concentration was on the another
level so today i'm was not able to to play uh as
good as i can but also he shows some something
that's i'm not expected right yeah and i mean
hikaru really i mean it was such a dominant
performance by you you're going to move on to face
wesley so somebody who you've played many times
in speeches championships past and recently
in the skilling open what is your mindset like
going into that semi-final matchup um i mean
i think it's more the same just just play good
solid chess um but certainly you know it's it's
payback time so um i'm gonna i'm gonna be out
for for blood i will i will uh say that much
um yeah but i think i think mainly it's just
uh just just playing well in general being
solid and i thought today i was very solid
um especially the five plus one three plus one
started to get a little bit messy at times and
i mean my concentration was really drifting uh
because i mean after winning that five percent
it just it felt like the match match wasn't
really uh competitive um but yeah mainly against
wesley just playing more good chess and um and
just uh just just do more of what i did today
and obviously wearing that hoodie because clearly
clearly that looks good on you feels good right
yeah but i mean like that wasn't intentional
i was gonna wear something else but then i
then i uh i had to i had to move a lot of stuff
over to my apartment this morning so i i like it
it was crazy i just threw something on but i'll
wear it again yeah i mean jokes aside it looks
to be uh look looks good for you um yeah well
again we don't want to keep you guys too long
we know it's late for you vladimir and again
uh you had you had an incredible year uh one
of the most consistent dominant players on
chess.com and in the speeches grand prix so
um we know today didn't go the way you wanted but
congratulations on a great year and uh and thank
you so much for for the interview here thank you
daniel uh thank you uh for a good match and for
all the viewers who probably enjoyed
this match i hope so thank you bye